crimes already have exemptions
established and a precedent has already
been established or is this indeed the
the first of its kind
uh well because the way it's written um
sewer law enforcement can get those
records upon request so all these other
crimes are generally investigated by
state certified law enforcement officers
i'm just in a very unique position i'm
not a state certified police officer so
i can't get those records
so any of the other crimes whether they
be whatever crime it might be they're
usually by real police officers working
thank you thank you representative
trottier
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my questions
you testified that you work with law
enforcement on these investigations now
and if that's so are they able to get
these records
and share them with you or if they do
get these records for their part of the
investigation are they not able to share
uh when i say i work with other law
enforcement agencies they're generally
not on my open cases so let's for
example today we just talked a moment
ago about the the vehicle that went off
the side of the road it was pulling a
trailer and it flipped over
and and i have access to all those
records i'll get a copy of the insurance
claims file we'll do our interviews with
the people uh we get a copy of the
accident report i'm really not involving
law enforcement in that case there's no
reason to because there's nothing that
they can do that i can't do i'm just
gonna do the same interviews so when i
say i work with law enforcement it it
might be
um i have a case of an insurance
producer stealing 200 000 from his
customers and it's a case that the fbi
would be interested i'll work hand in
hand with the fbi in a case like that
if i'm doing a search warrant on
somebody's premises or on a building
doctor can execute a search warrant i'll
work with law enforcement then but for
the most part i would say
90 percent of my cases i do without the
representative langley
thank you mr sharon thank you for taking
my question at any point has there ever
been any consideration to expand your
job description and your role to have
you become a state certified police
officer
um thank you for your question i've been
with the unit now for about 15 years and
i can say that there's never been any
discussion about making us sworn police
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on senate bill 288
we have a representative from 9-1-1
would you like to let us know what
is it on now it is
for the record my name is mark doyle i'm
the director of the division of
emergency services and communications
overseeing new hampshire's enhanced
9-1-1 system with the department of
safety
um
and a lot of questions came up that were
posed to
the insurance department regarding
the nature of the data that we have what
type of data we
are um asked to share right now and for
the record the department of safety has
no position on the amendment as it
stands
uh we're not the pro or khan however we
just want to make sure that when any of
these types of cases come up as had been
already alluded to by
one of the representatives on the uh on
the committee
could this potentially be a slippery
slope what's the nature of the
information that's going to be shared
we've heard testimony before regarding i
think environmental services when they
came before the committee to talk a
little bit about sharing address
information
we want to make sure that whatever the
information is that we're being that
we're sharing is information that's
going to be number one pertinent to the
nature of the request and secondly is
going to be protected at all costs
because as we've discussed before a lot
of that information
was obtained through a lot of uh i want
to say a lot of heartache but there were
a lot of concerns way back in the day
when
e91 went forward with collecting and
maintaining the databases where a lot of
this information is stored long story
short when we spoke to the folks at the
insurance department about what it is
that they wanted to do we recognized
that there was this little bit of a gap
between
what constitutes a request from a
certified law enforcement officer versus
what constitutes the request from an
individual who's conducting a criminal
investigation and needs that same
information
so we wanted to make sure again that
it's pertinent to the request and that
the information whatever it is that
they're requesting is going to be
protected at all costs and it's going to
be provided within very strict guard
rails
so when we've had the conversation with
the folks from the insurance department
we did our own digging to make sure that
those two points are going to be
addressed completely and we do recognize
that there are statutes in place
relative to the protection of the
information that it's not subject to
right to know that it is going to be
handled in much the same way law
enforcement officials around the state
maintain evidence and dispose of
evidence whether it's information or
physical evidence and we've got those
assurances not only from the insurance
department but they're built into
statute
along with that the statute requires
that the insurance department work
closely with the attorney general's
office whenever they conduct a criminal
investigation so we've got that nexus
between the insurance department as well
as a law enforcement agency when they're
conducting these investigations so we've
got assurances that not only is it going
to be specific to a criminal
investigation not unlike a law
enforcement investigation that
information is also going to be
protected so we don't have any heartburn
anymore about where that may end up that
it's not going to be out there in the
public domain that it's going to be very
well protected at the insurance
department best of based upon the best
practices they have in place when it
comes to maintaining that data and
holding it and disposing of it when it
needs to be disposed of
they're only looking for right now and
correct me if i'm wrong information
related to the timing of the call in the
actual call itself
they're not looking for address
information or any of that other data
however that information may come
pursuant to the criminal investigation
that follows up whether it's with a law
enforcement agency outside of the
attorney general's office or the
attorney general's office themselves
which can then obtain any further data
that they require
so again just from the department of
safety's perspective we don't take a
position on the bill but we do feel
comfortable and confident that the
information that they're looking for is
specific to the statute and within the
narrow guardrails associated with the
request right now is based upon the
representative smith
thank you would um this change require
rulemaking
it would we had just gone through that
last year
to change
chapter 106 h and the rules associated
with uh
saf c 7000 through
7013 which
is specific to the division of emergency
services and communications so we would
have to go through rulemaking to address
other questions
representative nader
hi thank you thank you for taking the
question i'm still trying to make sense
of
the
question that came through from a viewer
so yes there is a section three
but is it doesn't say uh
the words regardless of the use of such
information under paragraph one and two
so wording is important should those
words be included
i'll read them again regardless of the
use of such information under paragraph
thank you for your question
representative if i could look at
so the new paragraph to be added
regarding the information not subject to
right to know
through the enhanced 9-1-1 system states
to the insurance department in
connection with an ongoing criminal
investigation related to insurance fraud
or other insurance-related criminal
activity and this would be added in
addition to but not replace any other
wording
lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
you know
in the senate hearing that some
testimony was given that
uh by the insurance department that um
under the spill by statute all of the
records would be kept as confidential
and then they would be destroyed after
six years
but um are we talking paper records just
being a destroyer
internet records
electronic records thank you for your uh
question and i believe all records
refers to not only paper but electronic
as well so if we were to provide a
recording which in some cases we would
in pursuant to a request for
the data relative to a criminal
investigation any records that we would
provide would be destroyed whether
they're electronic whether they're paper
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question it might have been
asked already but how often does this
happen
that the need i probably should have
asked
the other gentleman i'm sorry but the
need um to
try to obtain these records
thanks for your question and uh
regarding the insurance department i
believe our discussions have been about
a half a dozen times a year plus or
minus
however other law enforcement agencies
will request them regularly and i know
the question came up earlier about the
process and what that process looks like
we have a standard process that we would
ask
we do ask any law enforcement agency and
we would
bring up to speed the folks in the
insurance department should this
amendment pass that there is a process
in place that they have to fill out a
form we keep a record of that form we
keep a copy of the information that we
supply as well so that there's an audit
trail associated with whomever it is
that we provision that information or
data to
so
if somebody needed to look back for
example to find out what was requested
by whom and when we have that
information in addition to the folks to
whomever it is that we provision that
sigmund thank you for your testimony
would you mind filling out just a pink
card so we can have that on the record
as well certainly mr chair thank you
very much thank you so much thank you
all
is there anyone else would like to
seeing none
we will close the hearing on senate bill
and move on to our next item of business
actually we gotta wait a couple of
hey
all right i'll let you get back to
uh whenever you haven't been though
and i'll be across the hall you know
in education so anytime you want to stop
over
sorry interruption
we'll call the committee back to order
our next item of business is a hearing
this is a bill establishing a commission
to study the landlord and tenant
mediation program in circuit courts and
we'll call upon the primary sponsor
senator perkinsquoka
good morning everyone and i'll try to be
more kind to you than i was the last
time you appeared before the committee
so
you know what chair it was it was an
unexpected situation no problem
um good morning everyone it's nice to be
here with you
for the record i am senator rebecca
perkins coca from senate district 21
representing the city of portsmouth and
the towns of madbury lee durham
newington newmarket and newfields the
prime sponsor vespy216
establishing a commission to study the
landlord and tenant mediation and
circuit court
sb 216 will create a commission to study
the landlord tenant mediation pilot
program currently ongoing in the circuit
courts
working with judge david king and his
staff the circuit courts have developed
this new program in order to work
through
issues between landlords and tenants
while trying to avoid evictions
we all understand how
important housing is especially after
the last year and a half and sb 216 will
give the general court and all relevant
stakeholders an appropriate venue to
analyze the program
assess what has worked and what hasn't
and make recommendations to ch and
changes for the program going forward
sb216 passed the senate commerce
committee 5-0 and passed the full senate
on the consent calendar
mr chairman i'm going to leave it at
that thank you for the opportunity to
present and i'm happy to try to answer
any questions are there any questions
it's your lucky day well that's too easy
sorry representative i'll have to change
that thank you mr chair and thank you
senator clocker um
so tell us more about um
the
pilot program
um i know that there's
tell us more about it sure yeah thank
you
yeah thank you representative de lorenzo
and i i neglected to mention in my
introduction that
representative delorenzo and i actually
worked very closely together on this
bill we had several
zooms back in the summer and fall of
last year with the with the judge's
office um
to make sure that this was something
they wanted us to take up and to see how
we could assist so
um the landlord tenant mediation program
has been ongoing for almost a year i
believe richard's going to come correct
me anything i say wrong um
and
thus far has been successful at keeping
up to 80 percent of the tenants who have
come through their program in their
homes so it's been a really successful
program and um
what the honorable judge king has found
is that a lot of times
the court doesn't have an opportunity to
simply
sort of
give air to to the
issues that have arisen between the
landlord and tenant pursuant to formal
procedure so this mediation program is
given a chance for
the parties primarily to do the work to
sort of you know work out these issues
between them um in a formal setting and
and in that way
allows the court to actively support
them you know resolving these disputes
in in a new way that's not as
procedurally stringent so
um i guess those are the highlights to
me um but i think you know making sure
that the general court kind of takes a
look at this model and
um you know potentially considers how it
can further be expanded in the future
would be a smart use of taxpayer money
and a great way to avoid
formal litigation where we could be
supporting
um
you know
more resolution of these disputes
outside of the court and also
accomplishing our important goal of
making sure people stay in their homes
so they can focus on their families and
their jobs and and being a part of our
society
representative chase
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question um i'm just
looking at real quick through your
report
but seeing this is a pilot program and
we're looking to make it a commission to
study when is the pilot program going to
end and do you foresee some issues
between that and hopefully getting the
study up and running yeah um
i am going to defer the question on when
it ends i believe it is uh later this
spring that it will come to an end but
um
that's part of why we thought the
commission would be well timed because
it would give an opportunity for
other stakeholders you know such as new
hampshire legal assistance and new
hampshire housing just to be a part of
the conversation on this program and
make sure
it's the best it can be
thank you
other questions i see representative
out of the corner of my eye
thank you um thank you senator
if the pilot program has been success so
successful
why haven't you come to us with
legislation to make it permanent rather
than to
set up a commission
that's a very good question
representative and um and i'll let mr
head speak to this further but um we did
representative delorenzo and i did ask
if that would be a helpful way to
support the program and
given that the pilot had not even yet
come to conclusion
the judge's office felt that it would be
better to give the pilot program a
chance to run its course
but i felt that
having a commission to make sure we as
the general courts supported the program
might be a good way to then come back
next year perhaps with a request for
appropriation to make it permanent
seeing none
again thank you for your testimony all
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch and the chair did
not say but i did sign up in support of
this bill
and the judicial branch does support the
bill
the
um in the
i just wanted
also i'm apologizing on behalf of
margaret huang who does all of our
alternative dispute resolution
coordination she had a conflict this
morning so if i cannot answer a question
i'm happy to get an answer for you
this program originally started in two
courts as a pilot
with existing funds that we have out of
our mediation budget
as a result of the availability of
federal funds through
covet relief money we were able to
expand the program so that it currently
has two
separate parts to it one is a pre-filing
program to encourage a resolution prior
to any filing of any litigation in court
and the parties either any party
involved can reach out to uh to the
court we can uh we do a sort of an
intake process if there are resources
that we're aware of that can be of
assistance to the parties we make the
parties aware of those resources and
then we try to resolve any disputes
prior to uh prior to any litigation
being filed
with the uh
with the data that we have that has uh
in the fairly small window of time that
i have data here november of 2021
through february of 2022
that had about a 68
success rate on reaching agreement and
pre-litigation
um uh matters
and then we have a separate program
in in the pre litigation is statewide
you can do that anywhere in the state
the the smaller program we have is uh
is post litigation so when it's actually
now been filed in the circuit court in
concord nashua in manchester we're
running a separate program
where all of the parties are offered
mediation essentially on the day that
they would have their scheduled hearing
so when they're at court for their
hearing they're given the opportunity to
be redirected into a mediation
and try to resolve that short of
appearing in front of the judge that has
the advantage of the for the parties of
letting them be in control of what the
decision is it does not always result in
a tenant staying in the apartment but it
may result in a process by which the
tenant will leave the apartment as
opposed to having a date certain it
avoids the uncertainty of going to a
judge and making a judge decide on the
matter and it gives the the really the
decision-making
over the case that authority over to the
parties
and what we've seen again in a
relatively small window
about an 81
agreement rate on those types of cases
so a very successful mediation program
in that sense
but
it's a fairly small
group of cases so far so
relatively new program
because we're able to do it through arpa
money we do have
additional time so we're hoping to
extend this program through the year
what i think the study commission would
do would give an opportunity for us both
to provide information to the
legislative body because if you do want
to extend this program it would be a
budget item next year so one it's an
opportunity to sort of educate the
legislative body on the program it's
received national attention it is a very
positive program
but if we're asking for money it's a
useful thing to to provide information
it's also useful to the judicial branch
because we can always improve things so
if there's testimonial there's a process
by which we would receive information
about how we can improve the program
we're always interested in that always
also so i think it does have a benefit
it's
we're not in a budget year so we're not
asking for for the budgeting items this
year but we think we have federal funds
available sufficient to carry us through
the year
um
so the so you know that would provide
the the overall benefit and with that i
think i'll
conclude my testimony and be happy to
answer any questions
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you
attorney head for taking my question
just out of curiosity because this is a
pilot program and i'm looking at where
the filing
was it conquered manchester nashua
that's correct
that's the only area so if you lived in
portsmouth you wouldn't be able to use
this program right now that's right so
what um what we do is we're paying the
mediators out of our out of the federal
funds or out of our mediation budget so
the parties don't pay for it but because
those are in the courtroom they're
physically there you know it's a limited
amount of funds available
we're able to do the pre-litigation one
statewide because those are done
remotely either video or telephone
so you know in that process we're able
to offer it more broadly but because
these are physically done in the
courtrooms or in the courthouses it's a
more limited program
and then we pay for the the cost of the
mediators out of out of our program
money
representative chase you want to follow
thank you
so
this is this is just where i just want
to understand all of this where the
courts are being heard but if say you
lived in portsmouth or my hometown
rollinsford and i had an issue i would
be able to file and go to one of these
courts that this is happening in no you
the what would be available would be the
pre-litigation so the parties who are
not yet filed lawsuits if if your normal
place to file a lawsuit would be
portsmouth
this program is not available in the
courthouse there
but anybody who would be able to reach
out call the the telephone number that's
on our website before litigation
and try to do a essentially a remote
mediation
i guess i do just
so it sort of gets back to what
representative smith asked and you've
given us all the reasons why the program
is working and why it's successful and
how it benefits both tenants and
landlords
the question i guess is
do we
what is ultimately the purpose of the
commission if it's
is it more than showing that the program
is successful i think
thank you for the question i think the
the benefit would be that as
we are developing this program because
it is a new program i think the
legislative body does provide sort of
unique form for
ways in which it can be improved so it
does allow the public an opportunity to
come and speak to the program where they
may not give us feedback in the same way
gives legislators an opportunity to give
us feedback
so that the program itself may be
modified through this process from what
we're doing currently
so
you know but certainly i think the the
goal is to have
provide information about the program
but also receive information about what
do we do well what can we do better and
what are the
what are the sort of the
what other input can we get that we
might not otherwise receive
and if i could
ask a second question and
i was just in another hearing prior to
us meeting this morning we're talking to
representatives from the court who
basically said we can't
accomplish everything that we currently
are doing
we just don't have the resources or the
ability to do that
is it under those circumstances do you
think it's advisable to take on a an
additional or a new program
um so thank you for the question i think
the
there are definitely resource issues we
have staffing issues in all of the
courthouses
we are currently down two full-time
judges in terms of of having folks who
have retired but not been replaced we
have a marital master who is about to
retire
and has not been replaced we have
definite shortages in the circuit court
system and that does result in delays
the benefit of this program is one it's
operated and managed out of our
alternative dispute resolution program
not by the court clerks
it is uh managed with mediators as
opposed to judges or court staff so we
have third party mediators who are
filling that role
and
and at the end of the day it takes
a certain number of cases out of the
system if they're able to be resolved
pre-filing which is ideal
it never enters the court system or if
it's entered the court system
it at least does not result
in
a hearing
relatively and and and this is you know
obviously part of the discussion
once you're in a
filing has occurred
and we're on hearing day
you know court staff has become involved
the judge has become involved in a set
aside time for that hearing so there is
an impact maybe there are ways of
improving that but at least the
mediation itself is done by
third party paid
mediators and at least some of the
coordination is done through a different
program within the court so it's not
impacting the same resources
so i think there is
probably some room for improvement and
the other way thing that we can try to
figure out is are there
are there other ways that we can
encourage the pre-litigation mediation
process and expand that
so that it never enters the court where
we can avoid it
thank you other questions representative
chase thank you thank you again um i
just wanted to follow up with my
question earlier about when the pilot
program is going to end and what's the
overlap going to be you know i have to
get a better answer for that i think
it's through the year but i i'll find
out for margaret and
send an email to the committee
other questions
sing then thank you for your testimony
representative lorenzo i see you put a
card in
i and i see you're a co-sponsor you've
already
sat as a member of the committee and
um tip which typically you wouldn't do
if you're going to speak
i guess does anybody have an objection
if representative lorenzo
i see no objection so well but that
should be a a lesson for everybody i
think in the future you
should not be
if you're going to
speak on a bill not be sitting on the
committee and asking questions
thank you mr chair and i apologize to
the committee for my little faux pas um
i had thought that i could only not
speak during executive session but
i was one
okay
mr chair could you could you just
clarify
that it is an executive session that you
can speak
it's in the hearing
okay
okay well i just wanted to talk really
briefly about my experience um with
mediation when i was a property manager
um
particularly in suffolk county
massachusetts which would be boston and
boston housing court
in the boston housing court
mediation was offered to landlords and
tenants
and
the mediation happened after
the case was um filed after after was
entered into the system um
on the day of the hearing the judge
would off you know the judge would um
ask if folks wanted to talk with the
housing specialist who was a mediator
and
i did a lot of those cases for
non-payment of rent and typically what
would happen is that
let's say a person owes i don't know 500
um rent and maybe it's a month and a
half no three months rent
um
what would happen is that we would come
up with a payment plan
and the landlord would sign it the
tenant would sign it and
once the
payment agreement was
fulfilled
the tenancy could be restored to full
tennessee but i found that it was really
helpful
um
it was a conciliatory process rather
than a punitive process
and
so i just wanted to let folks know about
that that it worked out for me as a
landlord it was wonderful
thank you
thank you are there questions for
representative lorenzo
represent chase
thank you again
and thank you representative lorenzo i
i'm just curious with the the payment
plan so were you in there you were in
there as a landlord yes and
so you had to agree to the payment plan
and keep this tenant there
if you choose chose not to you could
just have abolished that and
terminated the tenancy
yes that's correct thank you okay
sing then thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on
and our next hearing is scheduled for 10
o'clock
and we will be in recess until 10
o'clock i'd note that i have to testify
on a bill and another committee at 10
o'clock and i will be turning the reins
over to the vice chair representative
well good luck
do you have any other speakers or just
the only card that's the only card we
so good morning representative gordon
had to step out to testify um
on another bill
so i'm going to step in for him and
we're going to open the hearing on hb
297 and recognize senator carson to
morning mr chairman and again members of
the house judiciary committee for the
record my name is sharon carson i have
the pleasure of representing senate
district 14 comprising the towns of
londonderry hudson and auburn and i have
for your consideration
today senate bill 297 relative to
obtaining out-of-state discovery and
testimony
this bill allows testimony and discovery
from a foreign jurisdiction needed for
litigation pending in new hampshire to
be obtained without a court appointed
commissioner and pursuant to the
procedure
in the foreign jurisdiction
43 states have already adopted this
language and will simply remove an
unnecessary step for our attorneys while
maintaining appropriate procedures
um at this point i will conclude my
testimony there are
um there's someone here um from the
judicial branch who will be able to
explain to you why we need this bill and
everything else behind it so thank you
so as a co-sponsor on the bill i won't
be asking any questions but does anybody
else have any questions for the senator
representative chase thank you thank you
senator for taking my question and it
may be for attorney head but um
how often does this happen that
something is blocked because you cannot
get testimony from another state
thank you very much for your question i
completely agree with you i think mr
head is going to be in a better position
to answer this question than i am
does anybody else have any questions
thank you senator thank you very much
i don't have any other pink cards but
the senator did mention that uh attorney
desperately um
uh
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch i have a partly
filled up pink card i will complete the
filling out of that pink card we didn't
was not planning on testifying but
generally we would support obviously
this um
senator carson's bill
the
the issue is very complicated because
the the
um
and so in my experience in private
practice was if you need out of state
testimony there's a fairly complicated
process currently in place it is
possible to do you can get
what's called a commissioner appointed
you have to go to the local court you
have to get an order from your local
court you then have to take that order
go to the foreign jurisdiction so if
it's in ohio i have to bring that to
ohio i then have to do stuff according
to ohio law to get somebody in ohio
uh to get in order to have to get an
order in ohio probably usually
and then i have to
uh get somebody to make service and
it's a fairly complicated process and it
takes a lot of time
um so
and then i have to go to ohio i take the
deposition and and come back
what this there is a a uniform act and
in fact new hampshire has
partially passed the uniform act in that
if somebody from another state who has
passed the uniform act is trying to get
discovery in new hampshire
they can do that according to the
uniform act and basically just says
go ahead and get your discovery as you
would in new hampshire and you don't
have to do anything special it would
allow a new hampshire party to have that
same benefit when traveling or when
needing discovery from somebody out of
state
and it simply provides new hampshire
lawyers and new hampshire parties the
same opportunities that currently folks
in other states have when they're trying
to seek
discovery in new hampshire so it does
make for a smoother process it does also
eliminate a step with seeking an order
from a new hampshire court so a benefit
there for us
so overall it just makes for a much
smoother process and it only applies
where the other state has also adopted
the uniform
act
i would that be happy to conclude my
are there any questions representative
chase
i'm not a lawyer so bear with me
is it for say if you wanted to um
get information from
a company or is it from a certain person
is it something that may be
a crime that had happened here and then
the person lives in a different country
um
state and you need to get their
testimony i'm just trying to figure
it's i understand it but i want to see
where it fits so it fits in a lot of
different circumstances so
in in the context of civil litigation
there are people who may have facts or
may have documents who are not residing
in new hampshire and a subpoena from a
new hampshire court has authority within
the state of new hampshire so a new
hampshire judge cannot order somebody
who lives in ohio to appear
in that that that's where the rub occurs
we just have limited jurisdiction our
authority to issue subpoenas
so the
so anytime there is somebody who has
either
physical evidence that's outside of new
hampshire
or testimonial evidence that's outside
of new hampshire
the question is how do you get that into
new hampshire and into the case that's
in new hampshire we still can't
physically make them come to new
hampshire but it is an easier process if
it's testimony we can take videotape
testimony if it's documentary
typically what is done is
a party that holds a document you would
schedule a deposition but say if you get
us the documents ahead of time you don't
need to appear
things like that
and it just makes for a much
smoother process when you're dealing
are there any other questions for
anybody on the committee
that being said thank you very much for
your testimony thank you thank you very
much
is there anybody else that wishes to
speak
so the committee recognizes neil
nickerson nicholson nicholson yes thank
you very much good morning everyone so
nice to be here with you this morning my
name is neil nicholson i am a an
attorney that practices here in concord
at the law firm nicholson law firm i
practice mostly civil litigation and i
am testifying in support of this bill i
am also the past president of the new
hampshire association for justice
i'll be very brief i thought attorney
ahead did a very nice job summarizing
this bill and i'm going to synchronize
it maybe even a little bit further
the reason why
we are in support of this bill is number
one
it improves judicial efficiency
so by passing this bill
we will no longer have the need to file
a motion in new hampshire superior court
in order to get approval
to have another lawyer from another
state act as a commissioner
to take testimony or to otherwise gather
evidence in that foreign state so we
i guess
file a motion that's going to take time
and resources away from the judicial
staff and a judge in order to rule on
that motion which i will tell you most
of the time are assented to emotions so
there are situations where the attorneys
on both sides agree that this process
needs to go through
this is just kind of an antiquated
process that we're still operating under
here in new hampshire
the second reason why um testifying and
support of this bill is that it it will
actually increase the speed by which
people involved in litigation will be
able to get access to evidence so the
case will proceed in a faster fashion
which is always a good thing
rather than having unnecessary delay
which is what we have to deal with under
the current structure
thirdly and and i would say most
importantly is
by passing this bill it's actually going
to reduce
costs uh and attorneys fees
for people that are involved in
litigation so no longer will a person
who is a party in litigation have to pay
for an attorney
me
to go to that state wherever it is we're
trying to find a witness or evidence and
find
an attorney in that state who's licensed
in that state who would be willing to
act as the commissioner
and then spend time and money on me to
file the motion in court get it approved
hire the lawyer in the foreign
jurisdiction in order to act as the
commissioner so it would actually end up
uh saving litigants
money in attorney's fees which is you
know good good for them and good for all
of us so those are the reasons why i
support this bill i'm happy to take any
questions
does anybody in the community have any
thank you very much for your testimony
much i don't have any other pink cards
is there anybody else who wishes to
speak on this bill
all right with that being said i'll
it will call the house judiciary
committee back to order
our next item of business this morning
is a hearing on senate bill 301
that is relative to the procedure for
violations under the right to know law
the primary sponsor of this bill is
senator french and senator french would
good morning mr chair and entire
today the record my name is harold
french i am senator for district seven
and i'm here to introduce
my uh
senate bill 301 fn
in brief this
is relative to the procedure for
violations under the right to no law
this is this bill is designed
to
give
clarity to
um
to the plaintiff
on
what to do
if they are
denied
their request under 91a
and it gives guidance to superior court
on how to handle it
and uh
in brief that's what it's all about
so there are people behind me i think
that will be testifying and telling you
perfect thank you very much thank you
i'll remember that if you come to
thank you very much thank you
am i on now
okay
good morning i'm margaret burns i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
municipal association
we do not have a position on senate bill
301 we worked with the senate judiciary
committee to make some changes to the
original version of the bill just to
clarify a few things i have just one
very small comment on the current
version of the bill and that is in line
three as well as in line six
the bill refers to government government
records or information requests and then
in line six uh talks about the
production of government records or
information my very small comment is
just that under rsa 91 section 1a the
definition section
records are a
sub i'm sorry information is a sub
definition of government records so it
is really unnecessary to state both
pieces because government records will
contain information and all other
documentation in an ascertainable format
it's sort of a all-encompassing
definition so that is one very small
comment for the committee's
consideration
i have no other comments but i'm happy
to try to take any questions if there
are any
questions for mrs burns yes
representative chase
thank you and thank you for taking my
question would you just make it clear to
me what what are you saying take out
government records or information take
out information information and leave
the government records that's correct
representative smith
thank you mr chair um
can
you tell me why you are not taking a
position on this absolutely the way that
we read the bill it's putting sort of
guard rails and parameters around the
process and in doing so it probably will
benefit both plaintiffs and governmental
entities that are involved in lawsuits
related to governmental record issues i
spoke with some municipal attorneys as
well to sort of get their input and see
if i was reading that correctly and they
agreed that having parameters around the
process could actually benefit both
sides
and
therefore
thank you i'm sorry
so can you tell me why you are not
taking a position why you are not
supporting this
um
we're neutral on it because it doesn't
specifically fall under any of our
member adopted policies it doesn't
create new authority it doesn't erode
current local authority or specifically
fall under any of our member adopted
policies and in those circumstances we
are generally neutral on bills when that
thank you this is not the time to follow
up on that
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
laureato
good morning lori ordolano nashua i'm
representing right to know new hampshire
i spoke to this bill when it was
introduced over in the senate and right
to know new hampshire took a position
against this bill at the time the way
the language was written it included
submitting all responsive documents that
were provided
um to um
the um
respondent
and in some instances there's a lot of
documentation given that
did not need to be included in a lawsuit
for example i had a request for
information that i thought looks like
it's been amended and some of the
language has been changed
um
our group took a position against this
because we were
more interested and strongly supported
the ombudsman bill that is moved out of
the house and is over at the senate and
has been a work in progress for four or
five years
we felt that that position and the
handling of right to knows um in that
manner was sort of where we put our eggs
into that basket
the this change in the language you know
one of the concerns right you know new
hampshire had is it really doesn't
address it it addresses records issues
but not meetings rsa covers two types of
91a covers two types of issues document
requests that are not satisfied and
meetings that are not held correctly and
so this language seemed to speak to the
document issue and not really the
meetings issue so we didn't believe it
was
and honestly i believe this legislation
was drawn up because of things that were
happening down in nashua in my city um
there was you know some folks that
wanted to try and assist with what was
going on down there but i'm always
hesitant to create legislation because
of maybe the bad practices of one
municipality and transfer that through
legislation that has to apply to the
whole state so i'm really cautious about
doing that and making certain when we do
so so that's been our concern with it um
i just heard the lady before mention
that they would strike information for
the production of governmental records
or information because a lawsuit filed
under 91a would be a governmental
records suit but there is an
informational component to it that i'd
you know like to call out just for
awareness when there are exemptions
applied in your denied records under
exemptions the municipality is supposed
to provide a brief explanation of why
how that exemption applies and so that
would be sort of an information response
that could prompt a lawsuit
and in fact it's been a problem i know
in my municipality where exemptions are
given but an explanation for that
exemption or how it applies is not given
and that has drawn me to court to try
and figure out why documents are not
provided so that isn't necessarily a
records issue it's an exemption issue
with a lack of information provided in
clarity so in that sense information
could be
included when there's exemption
challenges coming forward
so
um
you know i guess
our position would be that maybe there's
a little more work in progress to go on
here
um
and the other thing that was discovered
you know i think the courts right now
are really struggling with right to know
issues the pandemic had an impact impact
the priority nature of getting your
right to knows through
because they're supposed to be priority
matters has not really happened because
the courts are backlogged so
understandably so but the other thing
that's been going on is that
i found there was an administrative
order passed in 2013 called
ao213-08 which calls out exemptions to
certain types of civil matters to be
exempt from trial rules and right to
know falls in that category it is exempt
from trial rules and there's a list of
rules that don't apply like answers to a
lawsuit don't apply
you know
interrogatories discovery that doesn't
apply
the judge can order it to apply but
ordinarily a right to know case would be
heard on a merits hearing
and i think the courts
to some extent have some of them have
forgotten that they're pushing a lot of
these right-to-know challenges to
full-blown lawsuits and they don't need
to be
it happened to me i just finished two
pro se cases they were full-blown lot
lawsuits i mean they were full-blown
trials
discovery depositions everything
um
and they could have been a merit hearing
which would have been much cheaper
and less time for everyone to go through
the reason i took them on myself is
because i knew they were gonna each one
would have cost me 25 000 to go into
court and i didn't want to spend that i
won the first one 99 certain i won the
second one
so i'm feeling pretty good about where i
stand on those but it was a lot of work
it was very stressful it's incredibly
difficult so i think trying to make the
courts and help the courts understand
and refresh their memories on
administrative order 213-08 is important
so that we can try and keep these things
as merit hearings minimize the impact on
the court the fees to the
the filer
and um
you know
questions
um
representative mclean
thank you mr thank you for taking my
question so is it right-to-knows
position then
that they think that the structure put
forth in this bill
um is too restrictive maybe pushing
people into a trial when it could be a
merit hearing and that maybe the
ombudsman is just the better approach to
allow more flexibility
i'm just trying to get a feel for where
you're thinking of going yes i think
that's a fair assessment we do think the
ombudsman is where we'd like to you know
focus our energies and our our um you
know time in that area and auditing that
should it take place and making certain
it's working the way we want it to work
and modifying it so that is definitely
where we want to go and we do feel this
is restrictive because it doesn't pick
up meetings
and we think that reminding the courts
of the uh you know when they go into
superior court to be heard as a civil
matter to try and focus them as merit
hearings and not full trials
represent mclean follow up thank you mr
chair just a quick follow-up so then
even if we were to amend this
legislation to incorporate meetings
you your position would still be one of
wanting to go the ombudsman route
yes
thank you
thank you represent mclean for asking
thank you thank you mr delano
is there anyone else who would like to
seeing no one we will
declare the hearing closed
thank you very much and
our next item of business
i thought we'd be running a tight
event
okay
um
yes
okay it being 11 o'clock we'll move on
to our next item of business we'll
reconvene the
house judiciary committee
our next
hearing is senate bill 222 permitting
licensing boards to conduct remote
hearings
and we'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative khan to introduce the
bill
thank you very much mr chairman
for the record i'm jay kahn state
senator
from
keene representing 15 of 23 towns in
cheshire county
and it's a pleasure to be
before
the the house judiciary committee i'm
usually on the receiving end being on
the senate judiciary committee so this
is a pleasure to see and put the faces
this bill
is
relative to the licensing boards of
the office of professional licensure and
certification
and we know that there are the 54
licensing boards
that
they
i began this conversation with
director lindsey courtney
because over the summer of 21
there were experiencing
professions
and
we
entered a conversation how can we
accelerate
uh this pipeline problem
and she described to me that they were
having difficulty achieving a quorum for
hopefully we are getting out of a
pandemic and we
don't face this but
as much but the fact still remains we
want to have as diverse a representation
on our licensing boards as possible
and diversity in our state often is
defined by regional diversity across our
state
often licensing boards have 90-minute
meetings and people are driving
two to three hours
to those meetings
and then
returning home in the same amount of
time
for a 90-minute meeting
and when we're talking about
folks that
are reimbursed a per client
were
digging into
the
earnings of
people that were asking to be active in
their profession
and to
serve the profession on these licensing
boards so that's what this bill is aimed
it is
very specific
to
as to where it's placed it's placed in
rsa 310
so that it doesn't need to be
put into every one of the licensing
professions but that
it would allow
each of the commissions to establish
rules that would allow it to hold
meetings
uh
electronically and other
providing alternative communication
opportunities for members of their
commission
and that's the nature of the the bill i
believe there's somebody here from oplc
uh to speak to this
thank you
and uh
they can give you more
details about which commissions uh
they've had the difficulties with
over the last year
representative horgan
well maybe he'll
defer this for when the abrupt oplc
comes but
what exactly happens at these 19-minute
they will review
licensing candidates but they also will
review people who have licenses and
have disciplinary
questions about those licenses
they also modify their standards for
licensing and rules that need to be
established
follow-up is this
so would these meetings are fair to say
typically of a large percentage of the
time spent in executive session if
they're discussing specific candidates
or
sometimes they do yes yeah right yeah
and i've i i say this when i was doing
legislation on
uh
medicaid to schools or telehealth
i
joined
the director of the department to meet
with some of the commissions that would
be affected by that legislation so
that's my
insight i haven't attended tried to
i guess if i had a question
it's
we've gotten
a number of bills having to do with
remote meetings over the last
year or two
and
it
it doesn't it doesn't seem like we had
this type of issue
prior to the covered issues so
i guess the question i have is
is this a this is uh do you view this as
a covert related problem
or
and if if it isn't a covid related
problem
why is it now a problem when it doesn't
i think
it's a great question to ask i i think
this has been a problem in the past
because of the distance
factor and the professional time
lost
more trying for people to
want to be at in-person meetings
but i think that this has been a problem
in the past
and the question is can we keep
active
licensed professionals
on boards when there's this significant
time trade-off
i'm not sure how well i'm going to do
this but is it
so good morning
my name is jessica calipalis i am the
director for the division of enforcement
at the office of professional licensure
and certification and i am here on
behalf of oplc this morning
um just very briefly um
oplc does not take a position on this
proposed legislation um however the
agency would note that there are no
number of boards that we support
that have been having physical quorum
issues as senator khan had indicated um
since they've had to come back in person
since the emergency orders ended
allowing them remote participation
executive director lindsey courtney also
provided a letter
which included a excel spreadsheet which
indicated which boards are having
issues and to what extent
so i would point that out to the
committee if you have not seen that yet
i think that's that provides a great
deal of information that you might find
questions
again if i could just say
it and i sit on a board
and when i accepted
the appointment to be on that board i
accepted it with the understanding that
i had to go to a monthly meeting
why wouldn't that be an ordinary
expectation for someone sitting on a
board that a requirement of being on the
board is you're going to attend a
meeting
that's an excellent question
um i don't have a great answer for i
haven't pulled all the different boards
that are having issues i have heard from
one
subcommittee of a board in particular
that is in the medical field and those
folks some of them are still treating
covid patients
so they have concerns about potentially
being exposed and bringing that exposure
to a meeting in person or they
themselves have may not be treating
some type of autoimmune disorder or a
family member does and they are
concerned about being exposed
so to some extent covet is still an
issue for those folks but i don't know
that that applies to all the boards
having this issue
and i don't know why perhaps it was not
an issue in the past and is a larger
thank you for coming today
laurie ordellano 41 berkeley street i'm
representing
right to know new hampshire our position
on these bills looking to
create remote meetings for boards has
been to oppose them
primarily because we feel a physical
location is very important for any of
these appointed or elected boards
we would be supportive of
relaxing the quorum requirement
or
revisiting the quorum requirement
particularly for
boards that have struggled i don't have
the data my question was going to be
what is you know let's look at the data
the oplc has 53 different boards and
there's one that's on the table to be
added that i'm interested in which is
moving the certification of assessors
and discipline over to the oplc that's
on the
that's a bill right now moving forward
so
um
you know
it would be nice to see how many of
those boards had a quorum issue
and if we need to make an accommodation
with that quorum for those boards then
perhaps that should be looked at first i
really feel a physical location is very
important
i'm particularly concerned
if the only means of dial-in is through
a telephone versus zoom
i think the um being able to physically
see people
and have a physical location where you
can address people talk to them before
after a meeting
express any other concerns you might
have if there is no public participation
is really very important and very
valuable
um
and i
i hate to see that given up
my sense was pre pandemic that a lot of
this wasn't nearly the issue it was
over the last two years and that we're
putting this behind us
now
and we should try to establish
business as usual as much as we possibly
can
so
we would like to see a physical location
maintained for these meetings
and
have our representative people available
to us where we can go and the other
thing is
with a physical location if different
boards through oplc are centered at
having people perhaps come to concord
there might be a better chance
that if the quorum's relaxed you would
have a zoom feed
a video feed where
anyone attending would be able to see
their appointed or elected represented
representatives performing their duties
are you familiar with oplc at all and
what they do
yes because i helped
create the bill to move
the certification of assessors and
discipline of assessors out from the dra
over to the oplc
last year and so i became more familiar
with their work and their boards that
are set up and we're looking now to set
up a seven person board
um to have
uh certification and discipline handled
through oplc
so we would be an additional one moving
it to like 55 groups and there's a fee
structure
nominal
to
be within that organization and um
so i have some familia they came in oplc
a representative came in and presented
to the assessing standards board
about their organization what they could
do if they took this on and and that's
why
our subgroup of certification move
forward with this legislation through
that
agency
the the reason i ask the question is
um
trying to figure out what role oplc
if any
attendance at
board meetings and
because
it seems like we have oplc now
with a much greater formality in the way
the boards are managed and handled
as opposed to prior to oplc
and where we didn't necessarily hear
about the problems that we're hearing
about now with regard to attendance i'm
just wondering and then this is a
question probably better directed at
ms calipaletis
and that is
do you think
that
this
oplc and the formalities of oplc and
the more requirements created by oplc
might have some role in
people's unwillingness to attend
um
i'm not necessarily certain of that i
you know i look at the assessing
standard board as an organization and
they take in um they're a
13 member board or 16 some directly from
the dra they meet in concord but they
have representation from all over the
state assessors or
um
uh select person managers come in from
all over to come to these meetings so
it's a it's a commitment and it's a
challenge to come but they always meet
one monthly and there is audience
attendance there's usually four or five
people that show up other assessors
other locations that come
speak they have a public comment
participate and give you know general
information as they're discussing
discussing topics and i think you know
if you took that group and you said hey
we'll just go remote with telephonic
meetings it would be an entirely
different
meeting format
and i think what you'd get from the
thank you
yes
is there anything else anyone else who
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on senate bill 222.
and we will be in recess our next
okay
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
and our next item of business today is a
hearing it's a hearing on senate bill
392 establishing a commission to study
insanity and restoration of competency
the primary
sponsor of this bill is senator sherman
and i see that he's here senator sherman
uh thank you uh
mr chair and for the record my name is
senator tom sherman district 24
representing 11 towns on the seacoast
which has had an interesting journey
it's establishing commission to study
insanity and restoration of competency
and actually
representative cushing was on this
commission on this council
the governor's advisory council on
mental health and the corrections system
and one of the
areas that we
identified as a as a council of concern
is restoration and there are people far
more qualified than me to explain
restoration
but it's really critically important to
protecting both the
accused and the victim
um that people who have been declared in
saying
go through a process of restoration so
they can actually stand trial for their
crime so that's
one part of this and i i will leave it
to those who are far better than me to
explain that
the original bill simply
uh redefined insane
and was a request of the department of
health and human services
the state statute on insanity has not
been amended since 1918
so
it currently
reads
this is amazing uh open quote the words
insane or insane person shall include
every idiot
non-compass that's c-o-m-p-o-s lunatic
insane or distracted person close quote
that's our current definition of
insanity
in
statute and you know distracted person i
think that'd catch all of us certainly
out on the roads these days
um
so clearly it does need revision but
when we actually revised it and it was
uh going to hearing on the senate side
the doj the department of justice said
wait stop we this will absolutely affect
cases that are currently in court
so
that's why we went to the idea of a
commission and because the two issues
are so closely related we brought in the
issue from the governor's advisory
council as well
um
recognizing that
there is a concern about more
commissions
i have two amendments and potentially
three depending on the will of this
committee
that would turn this into an executive
branch administrative working group
that's a mouthful
but we have done this really
successfully
with the medicaid dental benefit that
was probably the best recent example of
figuring out what the best answer is
bringing all the stakeholders together
without having to have it in a
commission format
they're very effective nimble
and as nimble as you can be with 17
different members but
it really would be a viable alternative
to commissions to answer these two
questions
in a way that did not impact current
court cases and and also really
benefited the state
so
uh
the main difference between these two
amendments all they're doing is taking
the bill the commission format turning
it into an executive branch
administrative working group
and the only difference between the
potentially
actually i guess there could be four
amendments is the number of people
participating on the house side
uh in the original bill there were three
and
you know it's completely up to you
whether you want zero one two or three
um but these two amendments are in the
form of three house which would be the
same as the current bill
or zero house members and certainly
all you'd have to do is insert a one if
you want one house we would like to keep
our membership on the working group
from the senate side so with that
[Music]
i can hand these out and answer any
questions for the
senator
would it be okay if we put four senators
[Laughter]
any other questions for the senator
i can leave these with you today that
would be great passed out
thank you very much for considering this
we have
actually i understand that there are
three
physicians who are here who would be
testifying together dr samantha's
sweater dr andrea mouchette from shay
and dr daniel
lampano
if that's close
welcome to the judiciary committee oh
thank you
um good afternoon my colleagues here dr
lampaniano so very close dr samantha
sweater um i'm dr andrea michette i'm
actually a licensed psychologist and the
director of the forensic program at new
hampshire hospital
um
as you heard from the senator before
about the definition of insane and how
it
obviously needs to be changed and
updated
um
and we also with the construction of the
new forensic hospital and how this is
like the best time
to review
the current sanity competency and
restoration needs of new hampshire
to make sure that they align with the
this executive work group seeks to
investigate this with collaboration with
our partners from doc doj as well as our
community stakeholders to establish an
executive work group
this large collaboration will allow all
the voices of the stakeholders
to have a seat at the table to discuss
the needs of new hampshire and our
clients
and
we didn't know if you had any specific
questions or clinical questions that we
are there
questions
yes representative chase
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
so in other states um
do we have a
what the definition is
like i don't even want to say it because
it's all so bad i'm sorry but is that
what we're just trying to comply and and
really bring things up i mean it's i
know i had read that before for
something else and was just appalled
that it and then also that it had been
from the 1800s and nothing had ever been
changed so
uh do are there examples or is that what
you're trying to do is just just get the
wording correct and and be able to
establish what we know now from what we
there are many examples across the
country with more updated language
that's a little bit more respectful and
then preserves the dignity of folks who
have been diagnosed with mental health
disorders in in the context of of their
involvement with the justice system um
and that would be part of the the
working group's um
scope is to kind of revisit some of
those other definitions and see what
thank you mr shearer and thank you for
taking my questions
i know that
some things have changed over the years
as far as mental health is concerned and
i believe that
alcohol misuse
disorder and
drug use misuse disorder
have
been
called disabilities
so i'm wondering if
diseases
related to um alcohol misuse and um
drug misuse
if those entered the realm of insanity
that's an excellent question um and
something that's been struggled with
over the past many decades uh as long as
as we've been defining uh insanity um
legally
um
that's something that generally has been
or often been excluded
from the definition of insanity but
again that's something that this working
group would be coming together to
to um
other questions
yes representative otter
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
i'm
why i don't understand why we need a
whole commission to just change a
it's another excellent question
this started out as something that was
very simple which was to address a
definition and what came out of this
process very quickly as we were
collaborating with our other partners in
department of justice in particular but
also the department of corrections was
that changing a simple definition is
going to have ramifications
elsewhere within the the systems and
that this also might represent an
opportunity to to visit other forensic
issues and try to improve those systems
across the board and that's why this
working group has been
proposed
other
questions representative macbeth
thank you mr chair and thank you so much
for taking my question
um
i'm wondering um
is
like situational insanity versus maybe
longer term condition is would that be
um
investigated or looked at by this
commission
and i'm i'm thinking maybe of somebody
also that maybe be unmedicated versus
medicated or or um in some type of
trauma or
crisis versus
someone
it's a difficult question
that we're
i think that um
what we could say is that
all these various scenarios
that that's why it's important to have a
working group so that different voices
and perspectives can bring various
scenarios to the table so that we're
thank you very much thank you mr truman
no further questions
representative notter
i hate to ask this let's
ask you to say some ugly words but i
can't i don't see it in here could you
define the current
work
what is the current definition for
insanity
for insane
um it is quote
shall include every idiot non-compos
lunatic insane or distracted person
is the current
isn't that all of us at one time or
another
yes
sure
representative smith
thank you
jim
mr chairman
as i understand it there are two parts
to this
the first part
and tell me where i'm wrong because i'm
sure i'm wrong
the first part is the
definition
of insanity
the second part
whatever that definition ends up being
is
how
you would
use that definition to evaluate
theoretically who has been receiving
treatment
has
moved past
the definition of insanity
to a point when they could be considered
competent
is that close at all to what you're
talking about here
not exactly it's a great question so in
order to be deemed insane you have to be
deemed competent first
so the goal is initially which dr bader
can also testify to
is if there's alleged charges
you know you work with your attorney and
the attorney
sees that there's a need for competency
because the person does not seem
mentally stable at the time so
competency evaluation will be done
um and if they are unstable at the time
they will be deemed incompetent to stand
trial for a period of 12 months for it's
a restoration period in the state of new
hampshire is 12 months
and then after that 12 months then they
have an evaluation again to see if they
were able to gain competency or
competence
if they received treatment and what not
if they have not then they are deemed
incompetent not restorable
and usually what we've seen is then
cases are dropped or no crossed
however if they are being competent then
they have then they are able to then
face their charges and neither plead
guilty not guilty not guilty by reason
of insanity or no contest
and could i follow it
thank you
i guess i don't understand
why
whether or not
the state builds a new
forensic
hospital should play any role in this
legislation if
we are suffering with an inappropriate
um
aged
and if we want to figure out how we
manage competency
the existence of the forensic hospital
or not is irrelevant to me
no ma'am
it's
the goal is to parallel the process
with the the hospital um
becoming available soon
well soon in the next couple years soon
and to be able to use that to streamline
treatment for incompetent individuals
you if i could just
please
thank you i was under the impression and
you know so much more about this than i
do
that all that the state has talked about
so far is
a facility there's been no talk about
staffing the facility about equipping
the facility about programs for the
facility
um
i am concerned that if in the fullness
of time
a facility
doesn't
come online
would not
let me know if i misunderstood your
the importance of this working group is
to ensure that the new forensic hospital
is as functional as possible in meeting
its mission
on the books currently there are certain
statutes
that
dictate that these individuals of
various legal statuses
ngri
sometimes incompetent to stand trial
will be treated at the state prison
under the the secure psychiatric unit
so it is important that if we're going
to use the new facility
in order to treat these individuals
that these statutes be updated and that
would be part of this working group's
scope is to examine
all of the aspects of of uh or processes
under which these forensic patients find
themselves and ensure that
the forensic hospital is functional from
a statutory standpoint
which can then be also translated into
uh staffing programming and what have
you does that answer your question would
you permit me just one more
certainly
thank you very much
are you saying that if there was not
a plan for a new forensic hospital
you would be content with the current
definition of insanity and the current
law
as to competency
no ma'am that's not what i'm saying
thank you yes ma'am representative
mclean
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions so just to clarify
whether or not a forensic hospital were
to be built
the goal of this is to kind of look at
where are the national practice
standards
and to bring
our statutory law
into alignment with those national
practice standards
whether or not a forensic hospital were
to be built is that correct
representative macbeth do you have a
question
thank you
so um thank you so much mr chairman and
thank you for entertaining this question
because i i feel like uh representative
notter's question run with me
but
then i read and i'm
you know so frequently we think of
insanity and restoration of competency
in the criminal aspect but i see in the
very first statement of the bill this is
also civil and probate court matters so
this is going to impact
um you know guardianships
correct and involuntary committals
people that are outside
oh
it's not going to affect civil
sorry could you say that again i didn't
if somebody is already on a civil
commitment
the civil commitment will stay with them
unless somehow they become justice
involved and then it would be a hybrid
of the systems working together to
figure out and compromising on the best
is there a structure for the
collaboration between probate court and
civil court
already or does that require rulemaking
as far as
somebody that may be under a
guardianship or involuntary commit both
i'm going to give this a shot
currently there are statutory
requirements as to whether somebody is
is um
is seen in probate court or superior
court
and we don't anticipate that these
that this working group is going to be
trying to change that
um i think it's everything downstream of
adjudicated in superior court or
appeared before probate court
does that answer your question
so thank you and
you know you're much you've answered it
better but i'm i'm just the example of
somebody that is under a guardianship
after they've already committed a
criminal act right so then this might
impact them or no because they may be
determined
insane
and the criminal charge maybe or there's
some you said the hybrid i'm not
familiar with that hybrid collaboration
is that in rules or is that just
i'm running the risk of saying too much
before we actually form the working
group and work some of this stuff out
but
what i would say is that um we don't
anticipate that guardianship is going to
be the function or or process by which
guardianship is determined would be
altered um by this process by by
these questions
so if i could just follow up one
one last follow-up
i'm hoping that you do consider though
people that may have been criminally
charged prior to the granting of a
guardianship and have
so maybe i need to be part no i'm just
so i didn't really i appreciate your
question because i wasn't asking for a
change in the guardianship process i'm
just concerned that this definition may
impact people under guardianship that
have been criminally charged
other questions
yes
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i would agree with you that the uh
original definition that goes back to
the 1700s is abominable and really we
should be embarrassed that we still have
it on the books
that being said i'm not clear as to how
we're going to redefine it and also
integrate it with the dsm
because a lot of work has been done in
terms of diagnostic work over the years
so it's hard for me as i i look at this
law to see how we're going to integrate
that work
with a more succinct definition of
solely
insanity can you help me understand that
better
yes
i think so
um fortunately we have many road maps
that other states have already trodden
in trying to balance this
fidelity that we want to show the dsm
in defining mental illness
and the legal definition
of insanity and how that's applied
within within the legal system
um
there um are
there have been trends uh amongst the
states that use uh one of
only a couple of standards
and so
i anticipate that part of the work of
this working group would be to
look at these standards that have been
established over decades have been
vetted through
many many many years of case law as well
and determine what makes sense for new
hampshire
other questions representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um you know as we
were talking about um
insanity and the the grounds for
insanity i thought about the mcnaughton
rule which is based in common law um
how is that applied these days and it
would have any would have any relevance
thank you for your question
the mcnaughton standard that you
reference
among those states that do offer an
insanity defense this is the most
commonly applied standard and so while
it does have a
a basis a tradition
in
common law
it has been statutorily ratified in a
number of jurisdictions
it is no doubt should this working group
be approved in form it would be
considered um
i could just so
you're dealing with the definition of
insanity and i understand that's part of
the intent is to come up with a new
definition but you're also dealing it
seems like the focus seems to be on the
court process
and competency
and my understanding
is that
the standard
for evaluating competency is different
than insanity it's not insanity so
is it
your intent to meld the two or are we
dealing with two different subjects
those subjects would be dealt with
individually okay
the
the second question i have is
with regard to the structure of this
working group because it seems to be
large and
i'm not sure how wieldy it is but
i'm not sure any legislators want to be
on it but that's another whole issue
um yeah
i i might assign representative wolper
um
so
long in the short is
uh on
it seems to me that you you've appeared
here today and we really appreciate you
being here today because you have
expertise
um
trying to figure out what expertise some
of the other people who have been named
to this commission are going to add to
defining insanity
or
even
addressing the issue of competency and
restoration of competency
would it
i'm trying to think in terms of
structuring the way that this should be
addressed i'm just wondering if it would
not be better
to authorize the department of health
and services to come up with a
recommendation and direct that they
consult with these individual peop
individual groups
in doing so
to be a far more efficient process than
trying to create a commission which
we've heard several times here today you
can't get a quorum for so that's another
whole issue so
i'm just wondering if um that might be a
what i would offer is that although the
department of health and human services
interacts with individuals who have been
deemed not guilty by reason of insanity
who are charged with attempting to treat
and therefore restore the competency of
those who are deemed unfit to stand
trial
currently the department of health and
human services does not make those
determinations those are made by
the office of foreign
with the aid of the office of friends
examiners under the department of
corrections
so you can see that already just on on
the face of it we have
already two departments who are very
involved in this we think that what we
have proposed or that what it has been
proposed
is
a good um
a good attempt to bring
together all the stakeholders who have
various
degrees of expertise in all these issues
the ramifications aren't just going to
be perfectly understood by the
department of health and human services
and while we could consult the
department of justice or department of
corrections truly within their realms
and way that it impacts the work that
they do and that
the citizenry of new hampshire they are
the experts within their own niche i
think it's important to bring them in in
a much more formalized
sing then
thank you for your testimony thanks for
and
chairman gordon and members of the
committee my name is holly stevens and i
am the
public politi policy director of nami
new hampshire
uh here today to speak in support of
senate bill 392
did want to take er enough the
opportunity to thank the sponsors for
being one of the named entities
on this commission i do understand that
there are some amendments to change it
from a
legislative commission to
some other working group under the
executive branch which we
would not have an opinion on one way or
the other
i want to thank the the committee for
as you've heard there's currently not a
restoration process in the state of new
hampshire and i'm going to speak to
the
restoration portion
and the
competency portion of this and not the
insanity portion of the spill
because they are separate and distinct
but currently there's no restoration
process and
at nami new hampshire we have heard from
families
of
their loved ones who have become justice
involved
that they see this as a missed
opportunity
one would think that
um everybody involved the families of
these folks would be
happy that after a year
competency hasn't been restored and the
charges are dropped
but what they really see is that that's
a missed opportunity for their loved one
um
what the families have seen is that
their loved ones go on to potentially
become homeless
commit other crimes
commit more serious crimes
or have other unfortunate
and there are mental health courts
within the state of new hampshire
but these folks
and i'm sure
the ag's office and other lawyers behind
me will also let you know that the the
mental health courts aren't an option
because you have to be able to give
informed consent and you have to
understand the judicial process
and those are you know um folks that are
deemed incompetent
can't give informed consent
and do not have the ability to
understand the judicial process at the
time
so therefore
and so this commission would would allow
for the state to look at
all the options that are out there and
maybe even creative and do what new
hampshire does best which has come up
with new hampshire solutions
and i know
chairman gordon you're concerned about
the unwieldy size of this
and i just wanted to let you know that
you know from nami new hampshire's
perspective
we do talk with these families
and we work with these folks and i think
that we can bring bring a perspective
to a commission
that we might be able to come up with
some creative solutions with the defense
bar
and with the ag's office
and with the department of corrections
and the department of human services
so that these folks are able to receive
the treatment that they need
and if they are restored
that
maybe there can be some other
alternatives for these folks other than
simply incarceration
that
you know given
their mental health status at the time
that they committed the crime
that maybe we can come up with some
other alternatives such as the mental
wealth court system
once folks are restored
so i would urge this committee to
seriously consider
voting this through as either a working
group or a commission
we are in support of this and i will uh
answer any questions that you may have
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
please
hi good afternoon my name is jeff
strollson i'm an associate attorney
general with new hampshire attorney
general's office and a prosecutor about
25 years now and have spent
unfortunately a lot of time dealing with
competency and insanity issues in the
criminal justice system
we are in support of this bill the
reason i want to come up is to be able
to answer any questions that any of you
might have after listening to some of
these the questions i've heard before
about how those two things work in the
criminal justice system and why we had a
concern about just changing the
definition of criminal insanity and what
that would mean and dr beta can
introduce herself my name is dr bader
i'm a board certified forensic
psychologist i'm also the chief forensic
evaluator for the state of new hampshire
so my office isn't responsible for doing
all the evaluations for competency and
sanity throughout the state
and i want to give a little background
about both those legal terms since we've
been talking about them a lot
the first thing to know is that
individuals with severe psychiatric
illness or intellectual deficits usually
need to well end up often needing two
different extra hearings when they get
arrested
the first one is a competency to stand
trial evaluation and then a hearing
this is really that requirement by our
constitution that folks are aware and
understanding of their of their rights
and what's happening at court
it's kind of a hidden process in our
state a lot of folks don't even know
that competency evaluations happen or
that this process exists but it's
necessary and is required and so if
someone is not well enough to be part of
their case then they're they're deemed
not competent to stand trial and then we
give a year for that person to get
better
now what's important is that our state
is the only state in the entire country
that does not have a formalized process
for folks to actually get better so the
court determines that this person is not
well enough psychiatrically
to actually be part of their case
they're expected to independently then
go navigate medicaid
make their own appointments arrange
transportation and get well on their own
i can tell you from experience that that
does not happen
and our numbers show that
most states show 80 percent of folks
become restored in their restoration
period in new hampshire our rates are
below 40 percent
this is terrible
and i will also say the folks who are
restored have a couple of things that
have happened one
their family members are involved
maybe they've been part of this legal
process with them and they are now you
know they found them they were homeless
now they know where they are and they
help
or two they leave the state they go to
massachusetts or they go to new york and
they're hospitalized in new york or
massachusetts and then come back
those are the folks that are restored
our process does not simply isn't broken
it doesn't exist
so as i said 40
of our folks are restored that means
that 60 percent of those defendants have
their cases dropped
those cases disappear
those victims get no day in court
they get no chance to have their
case resolved that defendant has no
chance to have their day in court they
have no chance for the court to prove
charges against them
in my experience attorneys lawyers
psychologists people working at new
hampshire hospital and nami we rarely
agree
about details we rarely agree about big
pictures
we all have very different views
all of us
agree that the system is broken and it
needs to be fixed and repaired
and i want to address what someone said
earlier about
why do we need a commission i've been
here for six years and i will tell you
that there have been actual earnest
driven attempts to fix this process
there have been these meetings between
dhhs doc the ag's office we've had
working groups we've had judicial
working groups there are county level
groups i have a meeting on friday at the
our month our quarterly merrimack
meeting hillsboro has been very active
we are unable to get to the actual
changes we need because most people
aren't able to all be there at the same
time as we've as we've heard we need
both new hampshire hospital department
of corrections the ag's office all of
those folks but we need the judges on
board and then we'll have a meeting and
we realize we need the new hampshire
mental health
system on board they're not at the
meeting this is the first time we've
developed a working group that may feel
unwieldy but actually has every person
that we need at the table
it also requires us to have deadlines
and a structure that has been lacking we
have gotten together all the time and we
talk and we talk and we talk and we talk
and we all say oh gosh it's so broken
having this working group as a judi as
an executive group in my opinion is the
first step we have to actually having
quantifiable reliable structured
deadlines which will make this process
actually improve
and i want to be really clear the
competency restoration piece is broken
we've been talking about insanity
this large group of people 60
of these defendants aren't getting
competent they don't even get a chance
to plead insanity
because they're not competent
they can't plead insanity they can't go
to mental health court they can't take a
very favorable plea bargain their case
is over
and i want to be really clear that folks
who are concerned about public safety
should be very concerned about this
those folks go to court
the judge hears that they're not
competent not restored
they leave
they leave they're not held
they simply go
and again we're hearing from nami we're
hearing from new hampshire hospital
we're hearing from all these other folks
that there's this high risk of continued
homelessness continued drug use and
re-arrest
at no point has there ever been a
discussion that this is something that
is a fly-by-night issue it's just time
and i think everyone on board is now
saying that we need help structuring
ourselves and having um some sort of
authority telling us to sort of show up
so i would just say comment about what
it's like from our perspective and
having to explain the victims and for us
this comes up in murder cases that
someone commits a murder
and maybe there are multiple victims
involved
that perpetrator is not found competent
to stand trial
and because of the system or the lack of
the system we have in new hampshire
within a year
if the court determines that person has
not been restored to competency which is
dr bader said in 60 percent of the cases
they're not
that person uh
unless they've been civilly committed
walks out the door and that's a very
difficult discussion to have with family
members
but why it is that there will be no day
in court essentially for what happened
here
i also want to explain that competency
to stand trial is different than
criminal insanity
competency to stand trial is whether or
not the person is capable of assisting
their lawyers and understanding the
legal process and competency to stand
trial can change
somebody could initially be competent
but then they're not taking their
medication not getting treatment they
could become incompetent they could
become competent again and incompetent
again
criminal insanity is a snapshot of one
moment in time
was that person criminally insane when
they committed the crime so it's two
very different things
and that's why it's important to have
very clear standards about one versus
the other the standard for competency is
pretty much universally the same across
the country there's pretty much one
standard everybody's developed
for the criminal insanity test there are
essentially four different versions of
it across the country and new hampshire
uses a version that no one else uses
the original bill
was well meaning to to change that
definition of insane
the problem is that it would have
changed the definition of criminal
insanity and that's what got our
attention
and the reason that matters is because
you have cases already in the pipeline
where one standard's being used
lawyers practitioners across new
hampshire you know what a certain
standard is judges do there are jury
instructions that talk about that
standard and we just thought it made
sense to really think before we change
the standard that we've used for
hundreds of years in this state
and so the standard for ins criminal
insanity in new hampshire is this
did the defendant have a mental illness
that caused them to commit the crime
that's the that's the question that's
the standard in new hampshire and so
it's different than
are they capable of assisting their
lawyers which is the competency standard
so i just want to tell you there are two
very different things
and the commission would look at
the competency issue
should we put a process together that
helps people become competent to stand
trial
and on the insanity piece it would be
should we keep the definition of
criminal insanity that we have or change
it that doesn't mean you couldn't change
that definition that's on the books
about insane because you can have a
civil definition of insane but the
criminal defense definition could be
different and so again that's why we
jumped in when we saw that but i wanted
to understand the kind of the scope of
the issues here and and why it matters
at least in the criminal justice system
and we'd be happy to answer any
questions that anyone has just when i
teach about this we always say uh
competency is current so when you think
competency is current and then insanity
is in the past so when they were
arrested were they sick at the time when
they were arrested competency is
occurring
and competency can change insanity is a
fixed point in time you're either insane
or not insane when you commit the crime
it can never change
and we'd be happy to answer any
questions yep are there questions for
attorney sterlison or dr bader
representative simpson did you have a
question
i do thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
i think we're hearing from you some
understanding of why this
either commission or
um working group
needs to be
so big but i just want to
drill down on that for a minute and i
think what i'm hearing from you is that
many of you on this list don't always
agree about these issues and your hope
is that if we
as a legislature
um
guide you direct you to all be in the
same room for the same amount of time
with a fixed deadline for
for change
then um
you would be able to come to some kind
of agreement through rigorous work and
conversation and
um
compromise and negotiation and all of
those things
is that true
yes and i think um what's true is that
we actually haven't all been together um
there's been you know even when judges
call meetings we can't get everybody
together the mental health system is so
separate from the judicial system that
it's hard to get all of us in the same
room so we haven't really all been
together about these topics
the other piece is that
someone could have a
could have an idea very well meaning to
change something but not realize that
that ramifications in another area
they're simply not fluent in
and so like i said changing the civil
definition of insane and not realizing
that the definition you punch in will
change the definition for criminal
insanity that's part of the reason to
kind of get everybody in the same room
not so much because we disagree but just
to make sure ah that's a great idea but
if you do that that's going to affect me
over here let's coordinate that better
and think about why we want to do that i
think that's part of the thought process
behind this
i want to add to that that you know as
clinicians we don't always think about
wording the same way attorneys do so
things like and instead of
or
can change entire definitions and so
that's why we need everybody there
together
tell me about your dream
[Laughter]
other questions
representative
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um there's 50 states so um do
the other states have this issue as well
or do
is there a state that has it all
nicely worded
uh for competency or insanity
for both so good question um so like we
said the the standard for competency is
is pretty much the same in every state
um in terms of getting people restored
to competency
every state has sort of different
versions
i think we would need a new hampshire
specific version of how to best do this
we have proposals that we've been
discussing as a large group but again
the mental health centers haven't really
been able to weigh in on if those are
realistic and we would need their
assistance
um so we have a lot thankfully because
we have no system we're not fixing
something we get to build it from the
ground up
and that's a great position to be in
because all other states have shown us
what works and doesn't work we can take
the best bits and build what i think
would be new hampshire's ideal version
um that's both
efficient and economic and and the right
thing for what we need and in terms of
insanity yeah i think
there are different standards and so
some states have chosen different
standards
and again we could look at see what
would be the best fit for new hampshire
some people are
are not necessarily dissatisfied with
our current standard again the language
needs to be updated but i think we've
never really had as a group a good
really
targeted discussion about what it should
be
i wouldn't say that any one state is the
shining example we would have to pull
from a variety of solutions
i mean right now the system that we have
for restoration of competency is so
lacking that anything would be an
improvement so you could certainly look
at what other states do and as far as
the definition definition for criminal
insanity the definition from our
perspective works fine
the question is can you separate it from
the civil definition just to make clear
that one pertains to one area one
pertains to the other instead of making
a definition that pertains to both that
then turns around and does this major
upheaval in the criminal justice world
what the definition of criminal insanity
means
other questions
i guess uh
it says that there'll be a minimum of 10
meetings with an account a year but you
have to make a report by
november
first
so
is there a need for 10 meetings in a
year
maybe instead of is it i can't remember
if it says you shall have i mean it
could it could be that you may have
shout
it turn it to maybe
that's because that's you know that
essentially means there's one month
without a meeting and here we are in
april so
it doesn't make much sense
certainly
we can reach that number by doubling up
in a month of course i mean i think
that's something you can leave to the
senators who are so excited to be
joining
um
but i will say that i think again having
that structure we haven't been able to
have monthly meetings with all those
necessary stakeholders so um
having a that due date
um and maybe splitting off into smaller
groups and having drafts all of those
things would be
why shouldn't we just appoint dr bader
as the
chairperson i can answer that honestly i
i i can answer that honestly i would say
that most people in this room i think
will tell you that i've been a chief
advocate for competency restoration
since i've took taken this job
and i have not achieved anything
um i feel like i'm a strong voice for
why we need it and everyone again is in
agreement but we have nothing we have no
paperwork we have not we have no
um
legislative proposals
and
i have we've tried pilot programs we
have tried a variety of things we are
i've worked closely with samhsa which is
a big national organization to try to
get assistance to come to new hampshire
and help us with this process
we still have nothing
so i would love to tell you that i could
share something and it would happen but
i've shown that i can't and that's why
we need this unwieldy group because this
is one of those things that needs all
the silos coming together uh to work on
and i guess the the only other question
i have is
basically as i look at the amendment and
i look at the original bill
it's in essence the same committee the
only difference is
who's going to
convene it that i can see
yeah i think i don't think there are
substantive changes
so it it gets changed from a
legislative committee to an executive
committee by virtue of who's going to
call the meeting
i think that reflects our desire to
actually have some movement and change i
think there is um
momentum behind this topic and i think
we understand that the we understand
that the time
pull for all of you is is dire and so i
don't we don't want your time needs to
necessarily block the
continuation of these processes that are
really necessary
okay any other questions
representative smith
actually represent mclean did you have a
question
i
am flattered
on behalf of the legislature
that you think we can change
human behavior
we can't
just want to make that clear
when i look at this saying
working group members shall be appointed
within 30 days you shall meet
i think it says within 45 days there
shall be
10 meetings
each of us sitting here
could list a dozen different entities
that we're familiar with where that same
or similar language exists where nothing
including the chair not
calling the first meeting
do you really think that by the
legislature
that the
the problem
the serious problem that you're facing
that i think all of us recognize
is going to get resolved
i think it's important to start trying
and that's i think what the bill my
understanding of what the bill is trying
to do is to simply start the process and
try
so
again from our perspective we support it
because it is an attempt to get people
together in a room to address a serious
issue and to make sure that all the
voices are heard so that nobody comes
back here with a bill
and then there are people lined up
raising their hands to speak to say why
you shouldn't do it and the question you
may all ask is why didn't you all get
together and figure this out before you
got here so i think it is it's an
attempt we all recognize human frailties
but i'm an optimist so
okay representative chase did you have a
question
thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question it's kind of a
piggybacks on what uh representative
smith said
i was thinking the same thing and also
so
all of these these entities that you've
been talking about are all on board to
do this you're just saying you need
direction and you need someone to put
the hammer down and say this is what you
have to do
and if that's the case
is is everybody in agreement that
they're going to be able to do this and
is it just taking legislation in order
to make that happen
i think too there's i think the hammer
is meaningful to me i mean i think
there's been discussions right among us
saying this is an important topic this
is an important topic this is an
important topic but the status quo has
been the way it was for a very long time
so i think in my experience too having
the legislature say no actually this is
important we do want you to meet about
this topic
has a lot of meaning to this group and i
will say that i agree with you this
question about well will people show up
i found that when judges say we're going
to meet
people show up um when we're saying
we're meeting about this legislative
you know post legislative bills such and
such you know 392 passing we're meeting
that carries a weight um
that
clears people's calendars a little bit
more than just hey dr bader would like
us all to meet and she's going to bring
donuts
um
that hasn't worked so far
so
i i do think there is a hammer
here that is
valuable
um and again i think there's also that
piece too that we're really hoping that
and i i do feel close to this that i
think if we have all these people in the
room
we have existing drafts of potential
legislation
we have to get agreement about how we
think about those moving forward we
could come back next session and say
here is our first step and we all are in
agreement everybody in the room
all these different people who never get
who never agree are all in support of
this
um
and we wouldn't have to sort of haggle
and haggle and haggle i do believe that
we are close to that because there is
agreement it's just these details
can i just also say that like all of you
right everybody fights for space on our
calendars and
we all give a priority to certain people
and for me and certainly us at our
office they'll say well we have a
legislative committee meeting i've got
to go to that certainly would allow me
or someone else to be like i'm not going
to do those 10 other things you want me
to do and nobody's going to give me
grief
so i think it helps all of us
meet those and meet those requirements
like it does all of you
so i just throw that out
thank you for your testimony today
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
it's a pleasure to be before house
judiciary today for the record my name
is john dejoy i'm here representing the
new hampshire psychological association
the hamster psychological association
represents psychologists across the
state of new hampshire
i'm pleased on their behalf to support
this important legislation
the psychological association respects
the breadth of stakeholders that are
listed in this legislation
one thing we note however is that there
are few clinicians
that are actually
represented in this list there are a
number of important people and for that
reason we would request respectfully to
add a
forensic psychologist specifically i
understand dr bader is a forensic
psychologist
she's not a named member although i
suspect she will end up being a member
of this and she should be
but we would ask that a forensic
psychologist
named by the new hampshire psychological
association be added to this
list and while it may seem unwieldy some
of the largest groups often end up with
some of the finest work
before this legislature
i would refer the committee
to the test submitted testimony of dr
james
bombersbach
dr bamasbach is a forensic psychologist
he's also a board member of the new
hampshire psychological association and
he has outlined the concerns of nhpa far
better than i could as their
representative today
and i think you'll find his
testimony
instructive
with that i'll conclude my testimony
thank you are there questions for mr
dejoy
thank you very much mr joy do you have
um
an opinion
as to
whether um
we should
stick with the language in the original
bill
which was to
create a commission
or
i don't know if you've seen the
amendments that senator sherman
submitted in which he suggests um
uh an executive branch working group
thank you for the question i i as you
know i always have a number of opinions
i'm careful today to represent the
opinions of new hampshire psychological
association
what i would say in response to that is
it's
as and i've read briefly
senator sherman's amendment
i was puzzled by while the legislature
would be directing the executive branch
to form this type of commission
committee when the executive branch is
fully capable of forming this committee
on their own without the legislature's
input
i do believe that the gravitas and i
heard your question before
representative i believe the gravitas of
the legislature is important in this
which is why i would suggest that we
ought to stay with a commission
you know it's interesting
you
several of you commented that you can't
make people do anything i think it's
absolutely true but when the legislature
speaks and forms a committee what i find
is you don't do anything to make people
be there
but you raise the bar where people are
afraid not to be there
people are always more afraid of what's
going to happen if they're not in the
room for that reason i think the
gravitas legislature makes this
commission valuable
and it's why i'm here before you today
representing nhpa asking that one of our
members be added to the membership list
because we believe this will move
forward
and will produce as i said a fine work
cnn thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
see no one we will close the hearing on
senate bill 392 and thank everybody for
we will move on to our next item of
which is senate bill 339 relative to
meetings of boards and commissions in
good afternoon good afternoon uh cheer
gordon good to see you again
twice in one day uh and for so
members chair gordon members of the
house uh judiciary committee uh for the
record my name is sue prentice i'm the
state senator from district five which
represents nine communities in the
beautiful connecticut
river valley of new hampshire right on
the vermont border
i'm here today to introduce senate bill
339 this bill exempts certain volunteer
boards at the new hampshire department
of safety from the physical quorum
requirements of rsa 91a while putting in
place measures to assure transparency
public access and participation
i'm going to name the boards in a second
but i want to make sure that i go on the
record saying that i did i worked on
this bill in collaboration at the
request of the department of safety
and that
years ago
i had the honor of serving as the chief
of emergency medical services for the
department of safety and i worked with
these boards
and at that time so i left the
department of safety in say 2010 so all
during the 2000s i would hear from
volunteers at all different levels
including you know volunteer emts
through to physicians who served in
different parts of the state that always
wanted to you know wanted to be on these
boards as well as attend these meetings
and couldn't leave their community
sometimes for you know the day that it
would take for them to be there to
actually serve so
uh i think one of the things we all
learned during covet 19 is that
in doing some of our business
virtually with putting you know the
necessary transparency and public access
requirements in place we saw
more public input
but also we experienced and particularly
on these boards and a member of one of
these boards is here today to speak more
people were actually able to
attend the meetings and i'll talk about
why that's important in just a second
but briefly
this addresses four different groups so
one is the fire standards and training
commission
that's established under rsa 21p25
the emergency medical and trauma
services coordinating board got the
department of safety which is
established under rsa 153 a3
the emergency medical services medical
control board at the department of
safety which is established under 153 a5
and the trauma systems trauma medical
review committee which is also at the
department of safety under 153
a8 each of these boards
dedicates hundreds of hours to assure
that emergency medical services and fire
organizations in new hampshire are
practicing and delivering services that
meet the highest standards each
volunteer member sacrifices time away
from work time away from home and many
travel from the furthest reaches in new
hampshire in order to be sure that
decisions are made with input from all
geographic locations
and again during my time as the chief
although we did have representation from
these different geographic rep
geographic locations
they need to be named to these groups
but they couldn't always again get away
from their their hospitals or their
ambulance services and they would ask
about this and then it seemed so foreign
but now it's almost so regular and
that's why this was
a specific request to come forward
now by allowing these exemptions i
believe that we will increase the number
of volunteers from the most diverse
locations in new hampshire that will be
able to serve increase the likelihood
that these volunteers will serve more
than one term and increase the input
from the public and the disciplines that
these boards serve i'd like to note in
terms of serving more than one term
there are term limits for each of these
positions they're i don't believe
they're for the medical control board
but there are for all of the other no
there is for the medical control board
now so they all have term limits but
what we have seen happen and it happened
during my tenure is it was such a huge
commitment and when it required travel
from you know close to the canadian
border to represent the emts from that
area or sometimes even down on the you
know we think of the seacoast as being
close by more metropolitan but still
when somebody has to is volunteering and
traveling and coming in to work on um
these different on one of these
different boards it becomes you know a a
day-long plus commitment so in order to
get them to serve for more than one term
to present provide some consistency and
in policy making
i think that this again is a real step
in the right direction
so during the senate uh when we heard
this was heard in house and senate
judiciary
we there were some concerns that were
raised um about you know the
basically the 91a requirements and i
wanted to make sure
that although in my mind
this would cover that these would be
covered i thought that it was important
to take the same steps that we took
during the pandemic for how these
meetings were conducted so that it was
the express transparency was there
so
this bill is now amended and it includes
a physical location so if people can
come to a meeting we're not expecting
that these meetings will come completely
virtual but folks that can come to a
meeting will be in a physical location
but it could be opened up to people
outside who are members of these boards
as well as members of the public who
want to have input it requires public
notice of meetings it requires public
access for participation it requires
that minutes be taken and posted for
public review on the department of
safety's website and it also has the it
requires a roll call vote if there is
any type of policy decision made say the
updating of a patient care protocol
again for the highest standards of care
that are available that we're we really
want to make sure that we keep
the public care and the public trust
front and center here
so considering again my time working
with these boards which again i was
really honored to serve in that role i
can think of very little that any member
has ever asked for
it's time we honor the work of those who
have served in the past those serving
now and those in the future
with making these changes so uh with
that i'd um
i'd ask for certainly an ought to pass
recommendation i'm happy to answer any
questions you might have and if i don't
questions for the senator yes
representative chase
thank you right now
so the meeting place is the department
of safety here in concord is that where
everybody tries and how often are those
held every other month so it's six times
a year
uh
it's six times a year for the medical
boards the fire student training
commission i believe they meet monthly
and they do travel in
there was a period of time when i worked
at safety where we did take these
meetings on the road but it became
really complicated in doing that when
you're trying to notify the public for
this meeting we'll be now at this
location so we just reconsolidated back
so at least six times a year for the
medical boards and um 12 times a year
for the fire standards and training
commission
you're welcome
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
during the past two years i've been to
many zoo meetings youtube
everything
one of my biggest drawbacks
is the youtube might not work you can't
hear the meeting and this happened more
than once
on a zoo meeting the people do not that
are
supposed to be in the room conducting
the meeting
they do not get close enough to the mic
so you can't hear them half the time
that's my biggest drawback how do we
solve it
i believe that uh
thank you um representative andrus for
the question and so on page two
of this and this is actually part of i i
skipped over this but was part of how we
amended it in the senate it provides a
mechanism for the public to alert the
public body during the meeting if there
are problems with access so
certainly i've attended more virtual
meetings um in the last two years and
even before that i worked in a remote
position for a group called the american
trauma society which supports supports
trauma centers throughout the country as
well as as here in in new hampshire so i
have a lot of experience working in the
virtual setting and by having that
mechanism in place where there's a
there's a notice for how to alert those
that are controlling the meeting that
there is a problem or that you you know
which includes maybe they can't get into
the room maybe they they're not being
heard
there's a you know they're not close
enough to the microphone there is a way
to have that conversation so there's a
phone number or a web
connection that they can make right away
outside of that virtual connection to
say there's a problem with this meeting
thank you very much
other questions
representative thank you very much mr
chair thank you very much senator
um
i'm reading um
especially paragraph four and page two
and then the rest of it looks like
this bill only guarantees the general
public uh basically telephone or
um
video streaming access to the meeting so
they don't guarantee
the general public the opportunity to
actually
be in the room and i think probably
probably our case especially if they're
meeting the department of safety under
certain circumstances where the
environment safety might want to limit
how many random people for the public
are physically in their facilities so
that's
this but is this intended to
guarantee all meetings in person access
or you're only going so far is to grant
them video or telephone access
without virtual act so thank you i'm
representative morgan and i think i've
seen you three times today so good to
see you again well good to see you then
so this uh this is a great time of year
we get to all see each other and so um i
i really appreciate this opportunity to
be here in person versus virtual but
during a time when we needed to do that
that's what we did so to answer your
question if we didn't even have this all
these folks would have to be in person
by doing this
and if language needs to be i'm
clarified i'm happy to do that it says
virtual which allows for
any you know any
whether it's by zoom
youtube
however it's going to be broadcast it's
a virtual platform
it's not been my experience
when i worked there that we limited the
number of of people in the room unless
you know there's an occupant so some of
this comes down to the local fire
departments and stuff there's a
certificate that says how many people
can be there so that includes the
buildings at the fire academy in concord
so if they were to go over that you know
then it would have to be what i would
say marshalled
i guess the the question
that i'm
wrestling with is um
we have this bill we've had a bill
earlier today with regard allowing
particular groups to have remote
meetings
we had bills
last year with regard to specialized
groups
or earlier this year with regard to have
specialized groups having
an exception for remote meetings
the issue that i'm having is shouldn't
we as a state be adopting a
policy rather than doing a onesies and
twozies for individual groups
shouldn't we have or be adopting an
overall policy with regard to remote
meetings
thank you chair gordon i couldn't agree
more
but in when i filed this bill there was
not there was didn't seem to be an
appetite for moving in that direction
and so what i did take was a step to
and i know that others did it this way
too to take these particular boards and
get them
hopefully across the finish line but i
think our larger goal needs to be that
we have to revisit the entire
conversation so i couldn't agree with
you more but in
there didn't seem to be an appetite for
something that was more broad
that involved state the state and state
boards so i narrowed my focus
that's the only reason why i did it this
way but i would be open and happy to you
know work on that on that type of
legislation
thank you you're welcome understandable
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much and again any
if you have any questions that i that
come up later you know i'm you know how
to find
me here
good afternoon i'd like to thank the
board uh for their time today i'm eric
martin i'm the trauma surgeon at
dartmouth tishkaka medical center i'm
also the trauma medical director there
but today i will be acting in my role of
the chair of the tmrc the trauma medical
review committee
in support of the spill i feel excuse me
for
some background i can only speak to our
committee i've been a member for a long
time um we are assigned the task of
maintaining the trauma system within the
state
by doing that we focus on the four
concepts of the pre-hospital care the
hospital care itself with the donations
of hospitals
the rehab part of this as well as injury
prevention so our meetings encounter
encompass all these groups they all
provide information and allows not only
the committee members but the public to
ask questions
it's it's a
great group that does this as senator
princess has said on their own time
we underwent a state review or a review
of our state's trauma system by the
american college of surgeons several
years ago and one of the things that
they were impressed by was the
equality of the trauma system that we
have and impressed by the fact that the
majority of this is done by volunteers
but caution against the longevity of
that
because people's time is harder and
harder to come up
i think senator apprentice has mentioned
this has been a challenge
before the pandemic we do outreach we do
education throughout the state
and every time you go to a small
hospital they are interested they're
engaged but trauma is a small part we
were in cobra class july great people
wonderful facilities
they are very engaged but it's very
difficult for one person who wears many
hats to leave their institution for a
day to drive down even if it's only
every other month
i think this is
pandemic has
broadened our abilities to engage and
capture more people
but i
i agree with everyone that there needs
to be a physical location i personally
feel it's much easier to have
conversations and engage and interact
with the physical location i think
having that as an option
is is very important
but we missed three of our meetings last
year because we couldn't get a quorum
and we only need nine people
people have gotten very used to
scheduling their time such that they can
block off an hour and a half for a
meeting but it's very difficult to know
kind of go back two years to where you
had your half half your day open or your
whole day open so i think
our group is such that everyone is
engaged and the key players will
continue to want to come but it does
allow for that option to say
you know we need one more person to
attend i have a quorum can someone call
in and just be a part of that meeting
and i think that would be helpful to
allow us to sort of move forward and
focus our efforts
and i think
you know i do appreciate that having a
physical location our meetings are i
believe we have 17 voting members
but we routinely have 50 or 60 people in
the room and those those public members
tend to be people who are engaged in
medical care but they are public members
and many of those non-voting public
members provide a lot of the services
that we do such as the designations so i
think we've never had a situation and i
would welcome the situation that we had
you know not enough room in our rooms uh
we've never had a standing room only
crowd i would love that but i think
space has not been a challenge in the
close to a decade that i've been part of
questions
yes representative chase
thank you thanks for taking my question
so tell me
if you when you're having your meetings
you said that you had missed three
meetings this year
and because you didn't have a quorum so
what happens what is it that you are
trying to vote on and does it get
curtailed and tabled to the next meeting
um so when our meetings we have
subcommittees that often meet at the
same time so the subcommittees are
responsible for designating state
hospitals they're responsible for
working on the pre-hospital care and our
education subcommittee which
is trying to more and more work on
outreach so i feel
the the last meeting we had in person i
was finally able to get caught up but i
almost feel like i have lost a year
because it's difficult when you meet
every other month to sort of keep the
momentum going but if you missed two in
a row which unfortunately we have it was
very difficult to sort of get back to
where we were trying to go
our efforts the past several years have
been there are 26 hospitals within the
state only 11 of those are designated
but everybody really is participating in
the acute care of injured patients
so our goal is to
engage every facility at some level um
and we've been working in that direction
to sort of change how we're utilizing
our resources but that does take
committee votes and
it's just has sort of stalled and we've
representative maclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um on the second page
uh paragraph four says that a physical
location
is required um but it doesn't require
that any member of the board actually be
there so while you might have a physical
location it would allow literally um for
nobody to physically show up to to
interact um with the folks of the
community that might be there do you
have any particular thoughts on that i
do and and i do feel that
again i i can talk to senator brentus
about this i don't want to change her
her language um but i feel that
like most things 100 of achieving even
six meetings a year can be challenging
everybody has problems even if you
have a requirement of
two-thirds of the meetings have to be in
person or something i can do all i want
to encourage people to attend in person
as the chair but if the language is such
that they could all attend remotely
i guess there's nothing that would stop
that direction i do know that many of
the attendees the volunteers and the
voting members use this as a
a
time to sort of resource with each other
and i think that physical contact has
been a strong suit of this
and i think
i would consider that i suspect that was
so going forward but i i share your
concerns as well you know we don't know
what will happen in five years and if
there's some language that suggests that
the majority of the meetings must be in
person as a voting member
that at least brings that core there
routinely
again that's just me i'm not speaking
for center apprentice on that one
thank you
representative
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question dr mark you articulated
something very well you said
i feel it but you i think you said
people are getting used to spending 90
minutes on something instead of a half
day
but i'm wondering for you when you're
participating in a virtual meeting are
you less engaged or less likely to
follow up with people that may have
questions or do you notice with your
colleagues on boards that they're less
committed to their service on that board
during the pandemic i hadn't noticed
that at all i think everyone is just as
engaged on the meeting i think there are
some technological challenges even still
two years into this
um but i felt like the work that was
being done during those meetings was
still effective i think it allowed for
some
some growth in some ways to be able to
do that without otherwise we would have
done nothing for for a long period of
time
but i didn't get the sense that people
were less engaged i feel the the key
point is having an ability for people to
raise their hand electronically or ask
questions is is you have to have that
you can't have a public meeting or any
meeting without the ability for people
to speak up
thank you dr martin thank you chair
gordon
just following up on what representative
mclean had asked
do you see would you have any objection
if there was a requirement that the
chairperson of a meeting be at the
physical location
i would not although i did miss the
december meeting for being for reasons
that i could not our hospital was being
reviewed by the american college surgeon
so that was one meeting i could not make
um so i think
if you wanted to have the language that
either the chair or the vice chair
should be present in person i think that
would allow for for some leniency
because
when you miss one meeting a year that's
a lot so if we were to say the presiding
officer the cardinals i think that's a
reasonable
reasonable ask so if the public is there
they would have
someone to
address exactly
thank you
thank you for coming today thank you for
is there anyone else who
would like to address the committee with
seeing nolan we will close the hearing
our next hearing isn't scheduled until
three o'clock so we will be in recess
mike's
good afternoon everyone we'll call the
thank you our next item of business is a
hearing
on senate bill 217 relative to eviction
notices the prime sponsor of that bill
was senator perkins quoca
and senator would you like to introduce
i would thank you chairman hi
representative to be with you again
today
for the record i'm senator rebecca
perkins quoca from senate district 21
representing portsmouth in the towns of
madbury lee durham newington newmarket
in newfields
the prime sponsor of sb217 relative to
eviction notices
sb 217 is a piece of legislation that i
worked on with elliot berry from new
hampshire legal assistance
as amended this bill will expand the
minimum minimum amount of notice needed
for a renovation eviction from 30 days
to 60 days
in such a tight housing market with
vacancy rates hovering between 0.5 and 1
around the entire state
it can be next to impossible to find
housing in 30 days with the threat of an
eviction hanging over your head
this bill is designed to provide a cause
of action for tenants in cases where a
landlord indicates the eviction is for
the purpose of renovating but does not
in fact pursue any renovations this is
clearly not every landlord in new
hampshire we are lucky to have small
local landlords and everyone has an
interest in preserving that
this bill is designed to provide some
remedy to the tenant
who is evicted under other good cause
leaving them little recourse
i hope that this bill will give
individuals and families already facing
a dire situation just a little bit more
time in which they could either find a
new place to live or find assistance to
help them catch up on any potentially
late payments
or find another avenue for resolving
their conflict of the landlord we all
know that the lack of long-term housing
supply is the real underlying problem
and one i have personally been working
on for over a decade
in the short term however over 50
percent of our renters were affected by
covert related job loss and we need to
continue to ensure that we do everything
we can to make our housing market fair
sb 217 passed at a center commerce with
the unanimous recommendation and passed
the full senate on a voice vote
thank you mr chairman i'll leave it
there and i'd be happy to answer any
questions are there any questions for
the senator
representative smith
mr chair
senator as i read this
i'm obviously missing something
the evictions here
have nothing to do with non-payment of
rent they have to do with
circumstances that
where the landlord
desires repairs or is required to make
repairs etc etc etc and yet you alluded
to
non-payment so can you help me
understand that thank you thank you
representative for the opportunity to
clarify that that was included in my
statement um
you're you are correct to read the
language of the bill to
address the limited circumstances where
um
we we're inserting
um into rsa 542 roman numeral to you
know paragraph h which does address the
specific circumstances you're talking
about when the landlord desires to
perform repairs the dwelling unit with
when the tenant cannot safely be in
there
perform a substantial renovation or to
sell
in those specific cases um
the 60-day notice is then inserted in
paragraph two
with certain exceptions so my apologies
for that being included in my
other questions for the senator
representative chase
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you for taking my question this is more
i'm just thinking of bills that we've
had already
for us
and i i could be
trying to pull from my memory it might
have been a lead paint removal but he
had one where um you know landlord has
been ordered to make the repairs and
then has to put the tenant in a
different dwelling uh whether it be
say a motel or something short term
until the repairs are done and then that
person would be able to go back to the
housing is this not
at all considered in the spill
yeah you're leading line 12 actually
yep
so if you come further down
yeah
that's all right
no problem
seeing none thank you senator thank you
very much
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
elliot berry i'm a
an attorney at new hampshire legal
assistance and the director of our
housing justice project i've been
representing tenants in new hampshire
for over 40 years and for some of you
you probably feel like i've been coming
um i think i've been here enough so that
you probably know what an incredible
shortage we have today of housing that
certainly even middle-income people uh
can afford and certainly
yet
in rental housing it's absolutely the
worst situation i've seen
in my 40-plus years here the median rent
for a two-bedroom apartment is just shy
two dollars shy of fifteen hundred
dollars and a vacancy rate statewide of
less than one percent
so at the same time
we're in this market we have seen
a major major spike in evictions
where the reason is that the landlord
wants to renovate the property or that
the landlord wants to sell the property
and the problem look is that in these
cases
the tenant is in no way at fault
whatsoever
but in this market
they may very well end up homeless after
living in a place especially i have a
lot of elderly clients who have lived in
their apartments for you know 10 years
or more and the new landlord comes and i
get it he you know wants to renovate the
properties but it should these folks
really be threatened with homelessness
remember that for elderly housing the
wait lists are
minimum
uh a year and a half for section 8 where
you have a subsidy that you can use in
the private market you're talking about
wait lists of five to ten years
so people just have nowhere to go
um
and i will say that again that this
market is the worst that i've seen
but i want to be really clear with you
we have never had enough rental housing
that at prices that lower income people
can afford
in my entire career here except during
the savings and loan
uh meltdown and then around 1990 and the
great recession in 2007 but other than
that the market is just
usually hostile to the people who need
housing
and can't afford it
uh i wanna
i wanna stress and this is really very
important
this is not about bad landlords it's not
about punishing any anybody it's simply
about giving people a little more
protection a little more time
so that that extra day or an extra week
or an extra month might enable them
to avoid
going to a homeless shelter or moving in
with people who don't you know with
relatives
um
you need to understand that this only
applies to what the law currently calls
restricted housing and what that means
is if you're renting out your
single-family home and you don't own
more than three at any one time
you're not affected by this bill at all
it if you live in a building an owner i
that you own and you have three rental
units or less in that building
this bill does not have any effect on
you whatsoever
for the bankers in the crowd
more
properties at mortgage foreclosure
are also exempt and this is not new
exemptions this exemption in the current
law
in the definitions of restricted housing
so what does the bill do simply it says
the eviction notice it's required
when you give somebody when the reason
for the eviction
is rehab of the building or sale of the
building it simply extends the eviction
notice from 30 to 60 days
um
the senate by voice vote passed an
amendment we had submitted the bill at
90 but i can't stress to you i just had
a client who i made an arrangement for
um to get her about three and a half
months to move after she had gotten been
in court for the eviction
for three when she got within two weeks
two weeks of her deadline drop dead date
she's still peppering me with emails she
has absolutely nowhere to go finally in
the last week she got a break and she
was able to move but i guess what i'm
trying to tell you here is yes
there is no question
that this will make landlords of
restricted property they it will maybe
lengthen the time it will take them to
do rehab or to sell a place but what i
beg you to do
is to consider balancing the harms on
the one hand you have people who are
being evicted to no fault of their own
who are facing the imminent possibility
of homelessness and on the other hand
you have investors in
landlords
who
simply you know who want to renovate and
rehab their property
but where it you know if you balance
those harms i don't think it's a close
call
now let me say one other thing that the
bill does that that should be of some
help if the repair is necessary because
it to remedy a condition that's a
violation of the housing code
the owner can go ahead as if this law
didn't exist as long as the land if if
the landlord first has to ask for an
extension if they can't get it that's it
if there's a lead issue the this doesn't
affect the lead law which has a separate
provision about evicting people from
lead
apartments with lead hazard it doesn't
affect them at all
um
i just wanna i have three letters that
i'd like to just distribute um one is
from stewart property management who
they own
2500 units in the state of new hampshire
and they
the the next one is from lakes region
community developers they support the
the third one is from
charlene
lovett the former mayor of the city of
claremont who's also on the claremont
housing authority and they support the
bill as well so i'd be happy to answer
any questions i'm sorry if i went on a
little too long but um i just urge you
to balance the harms and support this
bill
questions
for attorney barry
representative mclean
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um are folks that are
evicted um under this particular reason
do they still preserve the same due
process rights if they're evicted um for
other uh reasons like non-payment of
rent or things like that so is it they
sell the same due process the procedure
is exactly the same um but if i could
add it's which isn't exactly the answer
to you yeah your question
the one of the problems right now even
though there's a court process as the
chairman knows very well
but one of the problems is
the when a client
gets served with the landlord tenant
rift to start the eviction process in
court that gets
um that gets
scooped up in the landlord reporting
system but the reporting system doesn't
report why the eviction happened all the
prospective landlord sees is that that
person they that the land they prior
landlord filed an eviction action
against them and that is makes what is
difficult a market that is difficult
that's one more
major barrier to getting re-housed
but i don't know did i answer your
question
other questions representative horrigan
thank you very much i
saw all these three letters you're
handing out because they had i saw them
in my email and managed to
print them out so
two of them uh
officially they're stewards management
and lakes region those are both
those are both landlords who specialize
in subsidized housing so they're not uh
they're not part of the mainstream for
profit landlord commit community no
steward is is wholly for-profit although
he a lot of their profit a lot of their
properties do have units in them that
are subsidized but they are a for-profit
entity lake region community is a
non-profit okay follow up you may thank
you
um well thank you for clearing clearing
that up it did seem in congress for
a for-profit landlord to be talking
about something that benefits the
tenants but i see why
why
why it's a good good idea for him to do
that but there's a story in laconia
about a property where everyone was
kicked out within 30 days and then they
didn't start demolishing it for
six months do you know anything about
that story and that i don't know that
story but i'm really glad you asked
because one of the other problems that i
did not allude to
is that although most of the time this
is perfectly legitimate but a landlord
who wants to evict somebody
for some other reason but doesn't want
to take that to court the easiest thing
in the world for them to do is say i'm
selling the property i'm going to rehab
the property and i can tell you it's a
lawyer who's tried to defend i have to
tell those clients well what how am i
going to prove that you can't that
you're not going to sell it or you're
not going to rehab the property it's an
invitation for abuse now again i'm not
saying that's real common but i do know
it's out there
and at least by at least by extending
the notice period for 30 days you can
representative smith
mr berry i
i was under the impression that if
someone had a lease
even if the property
was sold
the lease continued to be in effect am i
no you're right about that but it's just
that there's an awful lot of tenants who
neither never had a lease in the first
place or their lease is expired and
they're going month-to-month i'd say
among my client
clientele that's probably the most
other questions yes
zen kenny
uh thank you for taking my question and
um my concern might be off base so lines
12 through 23 lays out exceptions and a
and b makes sense to me um i do have a
question about lines 20
uh through 23 the words health safety
deterioration are used but not
necessarily defined so i'm just
wondering if without definitions could
and not that a landlord would but
could those terms be used to justify
uh an eviction when renovation is is
needed
i'm really sorry uh representative kenny
i must have a different copy can you
what lines are you referring to
[Music]
um thank you
gotcha
um so i guess your if i understand your
question is is um
is there still the possibility that
landlords can
uh be telling lesson the whole story
about that absolutely um and
the only way i could prevent that is to
do something more draconian and i'm
trying you know i'm trying not to uh
have the uh
the perfect be the enemy of the good
here
thank you
i guess we the only question i have is
at least they were
a few years ago a couple years ago when
i got done
uh judges had the discretion in the
for people to
leave the premises
after that they determined that an
eviction was appropriate
anywhere from seven to ninety days it
said
seven to ninety days so
and i think it was always my practice to
hear from the tenants as to what time
they might need to get out of the
premises so
is that
presuming that still in effect and if it
is still in effect
is that not adequate or not
practiced well
it's all over the map
mr chairman i mean sometimes i would say
though in when i'm sitting in court
um and
just seeing these cases you know while
i'm waiting for my own i think
especially in cases when you're talking
about sales and rehab
my gut tells me that the most common um
discretionary stay is about 30 days
and is that is that enough often and
it's not and that's that's the it's not
because the market is so hostile out
there to people who don't you know again
fifteen hundred dollars is a median rent
for a two bedroom apartment
i mean
i have clients who've looked for six
months
um and this isn't going to solve the
problem but it just makes it a little
bit easier um
but you're right sometimes if you
especially if you have a very elderly
infirm client right who
uh you know the court's going to feel
sorry for sure sometimes he will get a
longer stay than that but as i said i
think the most common stay is right
other questions
representative did you have a question
sure thank you
um i'm looking over these um this
testimony from three different property
managers one of them is a former mayor
of claremont and a member of the hou of
the claremont housing authority the
other two are our property owners slash
managers and they support the bill so um
my question is
are by law do they have to kick people
out after 30 days or can they offer them
a lot to offer them no they cannot they
can offer as much time as they want
there's a i mean
the uh the law's requirements are the
minimum right and they're the minimum
and the most common but any landlord who
has uh
you know feeling humanitarian extremely
crowded that's when rental prices went
up here because you had
millennials staying in the rental market
longer retirees going into the rental
market and you had 20 000 new hampshire
families face foreclosure and we didn't
build anything
so um no i don't i don't think this a
sunset provision would be appropriate in
this case thank you for the question
sing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
once again for the opportunity to speak
um you know me pretty well i am an
advocate for landlords we have
a following of
2500 or more landlords across the state
i'm going to pass out testimonies
you can provision this this is called
for
in this which are actually
in the range of lines 18 through
23.
they're they're uh
someone already flagged out that they're
not very well defined
you could find yourself in court trying
to defend something that's
hard to define and so
then you may find out that that case has
been
um
it doesn't doesn't work the judge goes
against the property owner and so now
the property owner starts another
eviction
they started with 30 days then they
might restart with 60 and now it's
taking longer and longer and longer
also i'll remind and all of those delays
transfer into lost revenue which
also i just want to remind in case
people are forgetting that
this is only the first step in eviction
an eviction takes
with a seven day eviction takes about
six to eight weeks
so if we're adding
21 to
51 days
six to eight weeks is becoming 51 days
longer
so
there's also the discretionary stays
that can be granted and what we're
seeing in the courts now we're talking
about the difference in this market
versus previous markets what we're
seeing in the course now
is that pretty well all courts across
the state are doing everything they can
to extend the eviction workout
agreements between landlords and tenants
use rental assistance earnings
monies if it's the issues with money
so
we don't see that there's
we see a lot of harm that would come
from
forcing 60 days
and there's certainly a lot of confusion
in the language it would depress sales
any time that you extend notices it's
going to cause pressure on driving up
the rents it would delay repairs
you know it doesn't cure the issue
the issue is a shortage in supply but
this was totally right when she said
that we haven't been building enough
real estate
that's our issue
we need to focus our energy on building
more rental housing
and i think specifically workforce
and lower income housing
and the way things are in our market
right now
with the restrictions that keep coming
out in the eviction moratoriums that we
just got through
i can tell you
beyond the shadow of a doubt
there are many
mom and pop landlords
that are
leaving the business
selling their properties and who's
buying them
corporate investors
that come in
and do renovations and raise the rents
and every time that happens we lose
another piece of affordable housing
so anytime there's more restrictions and
barriers put on property owners and
landlords
then you're going to see it translate
into
less affordable housing and higher rents
i would certainly do delay
repairs for hazardous conditions
i wanted to tell you about my past week
just to give you a sense of the real
estate market because people are talking
about how hot and fast and hard it is to
get an apartment
in our office we finally put another ad
in the in the craigslist
where a lot of landlords put their ads
and it's been a while because not as
many people are moving
because it's hard harder to find a place
granted
i absolutely understand that
we put in the ad
within two days i got maybe six to eight
calls responses to that ad
i had three showings and i had one
application
that just happened this past week
now i won't say that it's not hard to
find an apartment yes
there's a shortage in supply
there's no question there's a shortage
in supply
and so it is harder for people to find
something
but you have to also realize that
creating a longer notice
from a landlord
is going to worsen the situation for
affordable housing because
a tenant is required to give 30 days
notice
so if a landlord gives
has to give 60
but the tenant only has to give 30
then the tenant that's been given 60
days notice is now out looking
and probably they're out looking right
away because yes it is harder to find
something
but are they finding anything that's
available 60 days out or 45 days out
probably not
because the tenant is only required to
give 30 days notice
so now what you're doing
is you're creating
another demand
on the supply
and when you have more demand on the
supply
for housing and there's not there a
landlord doesn't have it because the
senate hasn't given them a 30-day notice
then you're going to see more pressure
on increasing the rents it will worsen
the situation
what we need to do is make the situation
better by having more housing and i urge
you to support all the different bills
that come to you that would create more
housing
and and we're supporting those as well
there's a lot more in my notes and i
could you know i could probably talk for
three hours
so
i'll stop and i haven't covered
everything and i would be really
delighted to take any questions please
thank you mr norman are there any
questions
representative chase
and thank you
nick for taking my question
i just read this one area here that
you're saying the bill would delay
removing troublesome tenants that is
disturbing and threatening could you
explain to me how this bill is going to
delay removing someone that is being
disruptive absolutely
so the state has set up
several
situations that make it hard for
property owners
and when you have
a tenant that's causing nuisance to the
other
residents
you can evict them on a 30-day notice
but maybe not
because you have to get to court and you
have to prove
the nuisance you have to prove the drug
abuse you have to prove the drug
trafficking
i'm sure that
our previous judge can
can
confirm that
it's very hard
to to win an eviction case for for that
kind of a thing
or even domestic violence you have
someone that's a perpetrator
that you want to remove because they're
actually causing harm to others you have
to prove all that stuff
and
almost a hundred percent if you ask your
tenants
to testify in court
so that you can prove and win a case
they won't
they're too much afraid of retribution
but what you can do
and so one of the only things that the
state allows is you can say okay for
business reasons i'm going to renovate
that apartment
that's fine you can renovate the
apartment i'll renovate the apartment
i'll raise the rents
because i renovated
that's the only real choice that's
workable that's given to the landlord
and once again that worsens the
situation because now to get that tenant
out i need to renovate and of course i
renovate and now i raise the rents and
then i've solved the problem the other
people can live in peace and quiet
enjoyment
but
you've got one more apartment this off
the affordable list
representative representative macbeth
thank you um thank you mr norman for
taking my question
so is it your understanding that this
bill does impact nuisance evictions
nuisance um
well it would impact
so yes and no
so no
yes
so i have another follow-up you may
thank you so um i'm very curious um i
really am about your the ad that you put
in for the apartment
um
i don't base public policy on antidotes
but because i may want to help you with
public relations would you be interested
would you be able to supply that ad for
us so we could see
what you what sure what the unit was and
how much and what the conditions were
sure
thank you let me uh thank you very much
write that down otherwise it'll never
happen
sing then thank you for your testimony
thank you and please always reach out to
me call me in between times i'm always
the next person is sophia hyatt or
sophia i don't know
which which one is it it's sophia thank
you for asking how to say it uh my name
is sophia hyatt and i'm an attorney at
new hampshire legal assistance uh but
unlike elliot i've been there for about
10 months not 40 years so
uh unfortunately though in those 10
months i've had more than seven
renovation eviction cases um i'm going
to talk about some of them but i also
want to respond to some of the comments
that have been made
um with all respects to mr norman what
he just said about using this to evict
people for other issues is exactly what
we're talking about and changing it from
30 to 60 days will make it harder for
people to do just that and that's not
the purpose of a renovation good cause
eviction you know there are ways to
evict in the law for that and the court
process should be followed and not you
know manipulated and uh we shouldn't
decide on how to
adapt bills for something like this so
that a landlord can manipulate our court
system i would hope that everyone in the
room agrees with that
um and also talking about corporate
landlords coming in and buying up
properties that's already happening so
make no mistake that that's happening
already we're not you know if we don't
do this that's not going to prevent that
from happening that's already happening
here um
and also there was a discussion earlier
about
some of the sections in in some of the
lines and the exceptions and the 30-day
notice exception i just want to point
out that that language that's um being
referenced as causing confusion is
already in section
uh rsa 541 little a so
the alleged confusion is is from
language that's already in our statute
so i just want to clarify that
um so i want to talk a little bit about
my work at nhla uh i in 2021 our our
organization had 32 intakes for
renovation evictions
uh that was represented 30 different
tenants we had a couple people that
brought cases back
uh we had to reject five of those cases
uh like i said i've done and that was
just for 2021 we also do work in the
manchester and nashua district courts
and we regularly see evictions for
renovation in those in those situations
as well
most people that don't get legal aid
don't know that they don't have to move
out when their eviction notice expires
every client i've talked to in this
situation is like all right well i'm
packing and i have to move out and we're
like no you don't have to move out right
away so the id you know a lot of tenants
who don't get legal assistance and
remember i just told you we had to
reject five cases i'm sure that'll be
you know we always are rejecting things
unfortunately we just don't have the
resources
that there are people who are just going
to move out and they don't realize that
they can fight it and they think that
they just have to leave so that would
really help these people get either
reach out for legal advice by having a
little bit more time or just have more
time
to find a place and it is true that 60
days isn't a magic number people aren't
necessarily going to find a place
but it lessens the amount of time that
that person is homeless going to your
municipalities for local welfare dollars
and asking for them to pay for tran uh
transitional housing so
when people are homeless they're going
to your towns and asking for money so
that's something that you should
consider when thinking about minimizing
the uh i'm sorry you're not minimizing
extending the amount of time that
tenants would have for a notice period
uh one of my clients was
recently at the end of last year facing
eviction for renovation he lived there
for five years didn't want to move like
the town he was in but understood that
he had to move uh we negotiated a
move-out agreement he moved out and
three days later his landlord had
painted the property and posted it on
craigslist for 50 more
so
this is regularly used by landlords to
circumvent the legal eviction process
and you should not be
making your decision based on supporting
what you know to be manipulation of that
process
um
another client of mine lived in her
apartment my client's a disabled woman
and her daughter who's in college takes
care of her uh they lived in an
apartment for 16 years her landlord sold
the building and the new landlord i
understand they talked about you know
when a new owner wants comes in they
don't want to
make changes that's not always true in
this case that's not what happened and
she was evicted we did negotiate a
move-out agreement even though we
negotiated a move-out agreement she
still had to move in with another
daughter of hers 50 minutes away which
is 50 minutes away from her healthcare
providers and appointments so we're not
saying that 60 days is going to solve
the problem but it is going to help
people have more time to look for a
place and again it's also going to
lessen the burden on your municipalities
that you represent in terms of how much
money they have to pay out in local
welfare cases
um i also have a veteran right now that
i work with who is currently homeless
he's living in a temporary housing
he you know he's paying for
a five-day stay at a time we're working
with agencies to try and figure out a
place for him to go and he was evicted
for renovation so this is very real
again i've been doing this for
about 10 months i've had i think i said
like more than seven cases already so
just this is a very real thing it really
affects people and any extra time is
going to help people
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
viola
catasimo
good afternoon members of the house
judiciary my name is fayola katsime and
i'm here representing
the granite state organizing project we
are
a non-partisan organization based in
manchester that bring faith labor
community members together to fight for
social and economic justice
and i'm here today to really express our
support for sb 217
a gsop uh we are hearing stories daily
from tenants we've been running tenant
clinics for about um
six months now
in manchester and nashua
and most of those around evictions
over the weekend i was in a meeting with
uh tenants in manchester as well who
have received eviction notices to move
because of renovation i spoke to a
single mother with a 15 year old
who
doesn't know what to do um she received
a letter uh her rent is fifteen hundred
dollars
currently she's getting assistance
through the cup agencies to pay for part
of that money her rent went up by six
hundred dollars
and now she's being told that she has to
move out of this place
in 30 days
she really she expressed that she
doesn't know what to do because she's
looked around for alternative places and
she can't find any place that would take
her for that amount of money at the
moment
another family in manchester that uh
we've heard from
uh it's a a mother with two kids in a
two bedroom apartment they've been
living this building for 12 years
and recently
uh the
the kids grew up in that same building
so they don't know any other
neighborhood that's their neighborhood
they've been in and the schools they go
to
uh and so recently they've been
receiving notification as well that they
have to move because of the renovation
project that's going to take place
we know most of these buildings are
actually dilapidated they are very old
and poor conditions and the tenants in
those buildings do agree that renovation
needs to take place
but what they are trying to do is
trying to find a place anywhere in
manchester in nashua in concord anywhere
in the states is very very challenging
for these families and they have kids
they have
they have their resources within the
community so
what they're trying to
do is try and find those alternatives
the alternatives are not there that they
can afford so this bill would be really
critical in helping them figure out what
that next step is so i'm here to urge
the committee to consider passing this
bill and so i thank you for your time
and i hope that you will do the right
thing and support families in new
hampshire
okay
sing none thank you for coming and
good afternoon my name is jessica
marcherson i'm representing myself and i
am a tenant organizer with granite state
organizing project
i also run the tenant clinic that was
mentioned previously by biola which was
a product of going door-to-door over the
past two years to try and help tenants
understand their rights as it related to
copen now and to get through these mass
evictions
i am also on the manchester housing
commission to try and help alleviate
some of these issues
and what i wanted to speak to about
today
a lot of little things and i tried to
gather notes
and respond to a few different things i
heard this afternoon
what i do want to start with is mr
norman stated these renovation evictions
are being utilized as a quick no fight
eviction when they don't want to go
about it as they should and take their
chances
i stated this when we were here with hb
217 when it was in the house i stated it
seemed like a knee-jerk reaction to the
moratorium that was going on before
they couldn't they couldn't evict people
they were stymied and they found a way
and they've just taken off if you look
back over the last 14 years at least the
last 14 years i've advocated you've
never seen anything like this so to
speak to the sunset date no i don't
think we need to revisit it in three
years because i don't think we're going
backwards we've only continued to grow
and expand and we need to expand more
i don't see house prices shrinking i
don't see us
shrinking in the number of people so if
anything in three years we may need to
expand this
protections
um
there is as i said nobody checking on
these i had a family at 360 dubuque
street that called me up with a
renovation eviction and trying to help
them go through it the day they were
moving out somebody moved in
they know this because they went back to
get the rest of their stuff and they
were too scared to go in because the
other people were already moving in
there was no renovating
there was not even paint on the wall on
this i see this a lot and there's no way
unless somebody takes civil action later
to go back and say hey that wasn't a
renovation addiction i have some
families that have done the renovation
themselves
rachel gagne she would not mind me
saying this and she's asked me to speak
about her whenever i get the chance she
renovated with her husband their
building five out of six units
themselves turned around when the
building was bought and they renovated
evicted them
the people that actually renovated the
place
and as maintenance said to them they
were going to paint the walls replace
the stove add a heater and that's it
that's not a renovation but yet it's
being used this way
so
when we look at the stats we have four
to eight weeks for an initial
application for the nherap program
that's just a caseworker getting that
application and trying to contact them
and work through the motions to get them
in the program
that takes generally two week two days
to a week to happen that part
and it takes up to six weeks for those
checks to go out landlords are not
wanting to use this program that much
when a new client is coming in because
they know they have to wait for the
first month's rent the security deposit
all that stuff it makes it harder
actually to move with the program when
it's this busy because
as we've seen with that program it was
having trouble being able to upload
everything
so then we have
when you're talking about continued
assistance after the first initial round
and you go back to get more you're eight
weeks until you get a caseworker
assigned to you again
it is incredible weights out there so
you don't even have time to work with
those two months barely with that we
have 180 people currently in hotels as
of the previous state not today's date
so it could slightly change
waiting lists at shelters so before they
can even get to the hotel they're going
to the shelter but then they find out
they have a waiting list at the shelter
too where did they go
warming stations are shutting down if
you notice in your paper you see a lot
more homeless issues on the police calls
why because the warming centers are
shutting down and they're having less
places to go
and that's where our families will be
when they get evicted
um it takes a minimum of two months to
find a place and we have to remember
this is not just an address this is a
home this is where people have set up
their
custody agreements you've got to give 60
days notice on a custody agreement when
you want to move out of the city that
part hasn't even been raised
so
we could be changing people's lives here
a custodial parent could become
the parent that sees their kid every two
weeks instead because of this because
people are casting large nets when they
have to move
i would love to hear where mr norman's
apartment is because generally i hear of
500 to 1000 calls on each apartment that
is listed i am guessing and i'd love to
know the answer i'm guessing it's not in
manchester natural concord or around a
big city
and it might be quite high for rent
because the other problem we're having
is finding any actual affordable rent
because we waited a really long time to
start building it
and i am welcome to any questions
see none uh did you have one represent
chase
yep
thank you and just for clarification
thanks for taking my question so um the
granite state organization project
that's not the same as new hampshire
housing with a voucher because you're
talking you were talking about money
that's given to the landlord but they
don't have the first and last month's
friend so they're just given the money
it's with the nherap program they have
up to 18 months of rental assistance and
the one month security deposit is
separate from that
so when they find an apartment they put
their landlord information into their
case worker
and they start the process um that can
take about a week usually to have those
go back and forth and then you got about
six weeks till they get their check you
can ask to expedite it but that's like
two to three weeks instead of
i mean expedite sometimes you think it's
really quick but that's still two to
three weeks
um
and once they get in
what we're starting to do now is
immediately after they go through the
program and they get their money settled
what they're going to be paid out we
have them immediately do their continued
assistance application because it's so
long until they get to the next one
i'm actually currently in negotiations
with the large landlord in town i have
six buildings organized together under
one owner because they're all going
through evictions right now that's six
buildings in manchester
multi-unit buildings so as i explained
to them we got a clog in the pipe and we
need to kind of slow it down here
we got to let it trickle through how
it's going to
and let it open up a little bit so
they're willing to sit down and try and
negotiate because this is a lot of hours
for them in court also and if we can get
some moved around but this is the first
landlord
to ever do this
representative
thank you i just
so what i just what is n-a-g-r-e i may
be the only person that doesn't know
that acronym but i i just when we say
right the which one
i think i think you said nagre from
nherap the new hampshire emergency
rental assistance application program
other
questions thank you ms margerson for
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
i just i have a question mr attorney
barry if you just had another minute i
just have a question
it has to do with it this creates this
new section h the landlord desires to
perform repairs to the dwelling unit
which can't be done safely while the
tenant resides right perform substantial
renovations or sell the property
and
presumably
the landlord what i've heard here for
testimony today is that
these conditions may be used as a ruse
in certain circumstances that's what
i've heard for testimony yeah absolutely
i mean that's happening
without the bill there's no question as
mr norman essentially admitted it but um
right and he said because you have a
tenant you want to get rid of right but
you don't you're concerned you can't
prove it so you say okay i'll renovate
the property well and i think that's
what my
my question relates to and that is
the level of proof
that would be required at a court
you know the simple answer for you is
that you know the level of proof is a
preponderance of the evidence but um
i think normally in the experience that
i have right now i mean i think what
would probably happen is either the
landlord the manager and or the
maintenance people would come in and
describe what needs to be done
and um
you know what it could be pictures it
could be just you know verbal testimony
you know uh and
i don't think it should be all that yeah
all that difficult
so if and i could just follow up on that
because
it
seems to me if if the issue is that this
is being used as a ruse and that's
ultimately what the issue is and why we
have to extend the eviction period
why
instead of increasing the eviction
period or the the notice period i should
say in each case
addressing the proof that needs to be
supplied to the court in these
circumstances sure let me if i could and
then i'll address that in a minute but
let me make real clear or repeat what i
said at the beginning of my testimony
this by and large is not about bad
landlords and people doing this by and
large it's just get to get people the
time they need however
i think what you are suggesting
although as a lawyer i find that
intriguing uh i think you're probably
going to get more
uh a lot more uh blowback from the
property owner community than you are
with something that's you know this easy
but
um you know it's certainly something
that if the committee is interested we
uh we could work on um but you know i
mean if you think about it
and this is what happens all the time
right now the landlord simply comes in
and says what his intentions are
and it's like
you know it's hard to prove and that
prove a negative like i come back in the
court and say no you're not you know
the one thing i have to work with is
whether the landlord um issued the same
eviction notices to the other tenants in
the building but other than that i got
nothing so it but you know if you can
think of a way to
uh to enhance that burden of proof i'd
certainly be willing to work with you on
it well
and if i could just follow up more one
more time and that is
for example if you want to show
somebody's committed malpractice
you can't just come in and say they did
something wrong you need to have an
expert in the field say they did
malpractice if
if
you need to show that the repairs are
necessary and people can't live in there
it would seem that you ought to have a
letter from a contractor saying that
it's unsafe for people to reside in
there or if you're going to sell the
house
that the
new owner your the agreement that you
have with the new owner is that the
premises be vacated
so let me just step back a minute just
so everybody understands
if you give the 60 day notice under this
bill you don't have to worry about it
all you can still just go in and say you
know this is my intention but to address
your but if you want to go 30 right and
and deal with this proof issue here the
difference between this and a
malpractice case and almost any other is
that it's solely about the landlord's
intention right and you it is very hard
to say well no landlord you don't really
intend to do this it's not about with a
malpractice case or almost any other
case the question is did x happen or not
it's not did somebody inten you know
with criminal cases you may get into
intent but but the issue here is one
that in order to get the benefit of this
30-day exception if you will um
you you've really got to show that the
landlord's intention is not what he says
it is but again i think in the vast
majority of cases the landlord will give
the 60-day notice the tenants will get
the benefit of that and
you know things will work the way they
work now except the tenant gets more
time
i i should ask anybody else have any
questions for
attorney barry while he's up here thank
you for
second round
anyone else wish to testify
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill
and
unless there's some other matters before
the committee we'll be in recess until
morning if you say
i have to do a renovation so you have to
go while i do
there is nothing that gives that
priority
when that comes back on the market
right right right so no so so even if
they couldn't afford the increased rent
they're not given priority that's right
there's nothing that i'm aware of that
you